Five,
four,
three,
two,
one for sure.
Live.
No magical.
How are you?
You're a fucking responsible guest.
I just want to give you props for that.
You took your phone,
you shut that bitch off and you put it
aside.
That was a big thing for me also,
just as a comedian and comedy clubs.
You started seeing the comedy store
become popular and I started noticing a
bunch of chicks in there just looking at
their phones nonstop.
I even put this thing on my phone.
It's an app called moment that tracks
how long I'm using it and what I'm
using,
so if I get over a certain amount,
I'm like,
I get fucking put this thing down.
Does very smart.
We're all monkeys can look down at this
thing.
It's fascinating.
The dope of means of.
Yeah.
I have a 15 year old son and nonstop.
Whitney.
Cummings was explaining all the,
like the actual chemical responses that
go on.
Like you literally do become addicted to
that for sure.
And there's a lot of good shit on their
problem,
but I mean,
how many times do you find yourself like
about to go to bed and just like hitting
refresh,
checking twitter feeds.
Maybe some interesting news stories
coming up.
Maybe there's something I missed.
Let me check instagram.
It was a crazy picture that I didn't
say.
It's okay to miss it.
It is okay.
It's totally okay to miss it.
I go,
I admire what he did.
He stepped away from the whole fucking
smartphone.
Completely.
Just had a full conversation with him
about it yesterday because I said you
had three things happened that allowed
you to completely check out and go on
this trip years ago.
You have no kids,
you know kids.
You have no wife,
no family.
Which dog?
Dog planathon.
You wouldn't.
He moved to New York.
I sold him a soda.
Trey gave him all of my furniture
because he was moving to New York when I
was leaving New York.
So I'm like,
dude,
have all this shit.
Oh that's right.
You were there for the daily show,
for the daily show.
And then I took off.
I was commuting back and forth because I
left my family in La and I took the Gig,
so on Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
I'd work in New York and then I'd
fucking fly back to Jesus' horrible
mistake.
Trust me.
We talked about that before you did it
and I was like,
man,
I don't believe you're doing this.
I was killed myself.
My back is all fucked up.
I was telling a calendar,
like I said,
like I was a cashew shaped and jumping
forward.
Oh my God.
It's horrible.
Like if I cracked my,
my whole back when you were in an
airline seat constantly and you're just
constantly all stressed out and your
sleep is all fucked up.
It's not good.
So I got cast in another show.
I got the fuck out of there and I gave
already all my things.
So.
But already has,
like you said,
no fish,
nothing.
And then he is financial freedom because
he's got a,
you know,
the show on comedy central,
he's got a great podcast,
he's got all kinds of shit going on.
And then he also has this attitude that
allows him to do something like that
because I don't have those three things
I needed to.
Financial Freedom.
I got.
But I have these three dependents.
I have two dogs and have,
I don't have the attitude,
like if I'm not working nonstop,
I feel crazy.
You should tell people what you're
talking about because a lot of people
that are tuning into this podcast
probably don't realize that our Ari,
our good friend,
checked out of civilization for three
solid months at least.
Right?
I think maybe more.
First of all,
he's rocking a flip phone.
He won't,
he doesn't have any APPS,
so he doesn't.
Um,
he,
he has no smartphone,
but then he just decides to go away and
check out.
He'd no one's communicated with them.
You know,
we're sort of in business together on is
all things comedy thing.
And he's on our board of directors and I
need to tell him about shit.
And didn't even bother,
like he,
we did a skype and he's like,
I'm gone.
And then people on his show,
the comedy central show,
um,
they're trying to get ahold of them.
Nobody can get fucking ahold of art and
he loves it.
And me,
if I seriously,
I had to buy books.
Like,
you know,
I read a lot of Jack reacher.
Yeah.
Do you know that the best character of
all time?
Yeah.
Six foot four,
240 pounds.
I know Tom people associated with the
Tom Cruise movie,
but like this guy is the most bad ass.
He's a military cop.
Yeah.
How is the Tom Cruise?
A little tiny dude.
He just option the movies.
That's what happened.
My uncle skip Tarantino came over to me.
I didn't even know anything about Jack
reacher and my brother's wedding.
And he walks up and he goes,
can you believe they made Tom Cruise?
Jack reacher and I go,
what are you talking about?
There's a problem.
And he broke the whole thing down.
He goes,
let me tell you something about Jack
reacher Jack,
which is six foot four.
Jack reacher total bad ass.
He's he,
he's an expert marksman.
He's a 10 steps ahead.
He's a big numbers guy.
This guy,
Lee child created the perfect character,
but.
So I read all those books,
but I have to force myself to read those
books so I can chill the fuck out
because again,
and this is something that I'm a people
of other comics who pointed out I can't
be alone with my own thoughts.
Why is that?
I don't know because I've had some crazy
shit happen lately.
A dad passed away,
a lot of comics have passed away,
have friends with a ton of comedians
that have.
Freddy Soto was one of my good,
good buddies.
He's gone to.
But Dude,
I started comedy with passed away early
on.
So I,
you and Freddy Soto past me,
you know,
got me sponsored at the comedy store and
um,
I was very close to him like me and
Sebastian,
whereas openers.
And so I think that might have something
to do with it.
It's like I'm trying to get a lot of
great stuff happening,
but I feel like I distract myself with
work,
so I just keep busy as fuck a dude.
Enjoy work.
I love it.
I love the satisfaction of um,
I don't know,
like making stuff and having people
enjoy it.
So you feel like,
I mean,
it seems like you love doing standup
when I see her at the store and you're
going up.
Looks like you're having a great time,
a great time hanging out with other
comics.
I love the comedy store.
I love what the comedy store is.
I love what it always has been.
I love how it's had this resurgence.
I love the fact that they don't let
everybody in there.
Isn't that great?
It is great.
There's a lot of people that are trying
to get in there and they're like,
eh,
we're good.
Yeah.
And there's a lot of comics that you
think are great.
Come.
Mitzi had a weird thing like she didn't
pass Louis,
like,
that's,
that's crazy.
And then there was gatekeeper Tommy
there for a while who wouldn't pass,
like was holding the torch for Mitzi and
what her,
you know,
we needed a weird thing with black eyes,
like
the best dude.
But then I'll just add a megan come in.
I've been so polite.
But then I love the fact that like me
and you get to hang out at that back bar
like that.
They made that for us was really fucking
smart within the last two years they
made this.
If you guys don't know what we're
talking about,
the.
They made this video room that was just
a room in the back behind the kitchen.
And he said,
the comics love hanging out here.
Let's create a special little backbar
just for the comedians and their
friends.
And uh,
we get to have conversations in there.
And you had some weird thing somebody
told me the other night when I was in
there like,
fucking some chick was in here taking
pictures.
She was filming.
Oh yeah,
you shouldn't be filming to Santinello.
And I having a conversation.
And Brian Red Band Carter filming.
You can't do that.
To do that,
but if it's a private bar,
yeah,
like you're not even supposed to be back
there unless you're a comic or a friend
of a calmer.
Exactly.
So,
and that's great for us because,
you know,
none we light,
I,
I enjoy talking to people as much but
sometimes just gets overwhelming.
And then also I want to have a
conversation with you or any of my
friends are real one normal conversation
where you can talk at length with
somebody and you can't do that and it
seems like you're getting interrupted
nonstop.
Just again,
happy to.
I'm still the type of guy after shows.
I'll go out,
say hello to everybody talk,
you know,
and uh,
but when all my friends are around and
that's one of the great parts about the
comedy store.
And again,
the,
another part about the comedy store is
then you have to get past.
He had to be a paid regular.
Yeah.
It is.
Also,
there's like,
there's a bunch of hot spots there where
you get stuck.
Like if you're trying to do your set and
you're leaving the back bar and you're
trying to get to the,
oh,
are you going through that hallway?
You'll just get stuck by people with
cameras.
They just want to take pictures.
They just wait.
They just waiting like owls ready to
swooped down and snatched a rabbit.
They're just waiting,
waiting,
and there's al.
Can I get a picture?
And you're like,
I got to do.
I sat and like literally walk outside.
Just real quiCk.
Just real quick.
Like walking to the staIrs.
I've seen it.
Yeah.
It's like fucking crushed.
It really is when it's at the comedy
cellar in New York and the comedy store
in los angeles
or the best comedy clubs in the country
and if you're a comedy fan listening to
this and you,
you got to make the trip.
They really do because it's words on
tuesday night,
wednesday night,
thursday night.
You're going to see an amazing show that
could be in a stadium.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
I mean some of the,
the show someone,
the lineups,
like you guys have a show there next
wednesday,
all things comedy.
You,
bert kreischer,
who else is on?
No,
I'm aCtually not even unexcIting.
We go to Mexico.
No,
it's,
it's burt and bill and then you know a
couple other atc comics.
the united see,
but the last one we did.
You did.
And then sarah silverman was on it.
It was so.
It was used.
Sera silverman,
eddie pepitone like this great.
Meg bearer was on that one.
Yeah.
They're insane.
Yeah,
it was a.
It was.
It's a great,
great place to hang out and so I love
that.
I love doing standup and I love hanging
out with my friends and that's a huge
part.
But you feel like you're distracting
yourself with work.
I brought something.
You made a great point the other night
because I,
we were talking about having an
assistant.
You go,
I don't want to be busy enough to have
an assistant.
I don't want to be that busy.
When I get to assistant level in my car
thinking about assistant,
you take it down.
Well,
that's my manager.
They came up to me and they said,
we think you should get an assistant.
I said,
I'll,
I'll definitely start doing less shit.
I go,
let's just stop doing whatever I'm doing
that I'm doing too much,
that I need an assistant to stop.
And they're like,
well,
sometimes it's hard to get ahold of
yoga.
Well that's on purpose.
Like do you understand that?
Like bill murrAy has a one 800 number.
They.
Because they.
Yeah.
If you want to get ahold of bill murray,
you get the one 800 number and then
maybe he'll call you back.
really?
Yep.
So people leave messages on the one 800
number or something?
Yeah.
If you're.
I mean if you're calling about him being
in a major motion picture,
that's how you get ahold of the filmer.
Will bill murray apparently checked out
of relationships a few years ago?
We said no more relationships.
I don't want a girlfriend.
I don't want a wife.
I'm done.
He has a kid.
I guess apparently it's got an older kid
checked out and he moved to like North
Carolina or South Carolina,
lIke one of those fucking places and
anthony bordain interviewed him on his
show,
you know,
we had him on the show and he's like,
what are you doing down here?
And he's like,
I love it.
It's great.
Please call.
nice.
Yeah.
And he also,
for a while I was living in upstate New
York,
like up the hudson who would live up
there.
Same sort of deal.
Just just I'm done like I'm just going
to live in weird spots and I'm by
myself.
So that's another reason why I'm working
my ass off is I want that I'm done,
fuck you money and I want to be able to
chill out.
I got kids on the back end of this thing
where they're almost out of the house.
Like I'm looking forward to that where
they're both going to be in college and
trying to get these little fuckers ready
for life to the point where they don't
need to come back because you hear a lot
of people who are living in their homes
with their parents until they're 30 and
later.
What the fuck is that?
Not acceptable.
I'm
going to push you out the door now.
Someone is 36.
Not good.
Yeah.
What will they're making?
Life is too good,
I guess.
Yeah,
it's too easy.
there's no.
I was listening to dr.
Drew talk about this on a howard stern
ramp up show and he was saying like,
kids don't have grit.
Grit,
grit.
Oh,
associate.
Dr drew with grit.
Well,
you're Just,
you know,
he knows about a hustle,
hustle and he goes,
my kids are coddled,
but he thinks the only thing is the
educational system pushing education,
make somebody work their ass off if you
don't have that inner drive.
And the reason like getting with me,
and this was world,
so if I,
I don't see a therapist,
I probably should because they got a lot
going on,
but fucking my mom was cleaning houses
and making $6 an hour.
My dad,
teamster,
warehouse foreman and uh,
they were poor growing up,
lower middle class and then went to the
school.
He sent me to school in san francisco
with all these rich kids as well as in
all these rich houses and houses in
people who know san francisco is pacific
heights is really nice and sold it now
it's like fucking $12,000,000 houses.
And that's where we were hanging out.
Parents would have abandoned them on the
weekends and we'd have run of these
fucking houses.
Just crazy.
Like my buddy broke a $25,000 vase and
sort of like,
let's get the fuck outta here.
We'll pay for it.
And we were in all these.
I was like smoking some guys,
cubans on sitting in his chair.
I'm a kid from the inner sunset district
who shouldn't be all of these places.
But I think that's what lit a fire under
my aunts because I'm working for the.
My mom eventually has this great rags to
riches story where she was working at
this company and then she became an
account rep and then she became the head
account rep.
Then she began to vice president.
Then she bought the company and
quadrupled the company in size.
Wow.
And that's where I went to work for her.
Even though I wanted to be a standup
comic,
I go to work for her.
I am firing people for living,
which is a whole nother fucking thing.
And Just say I really was forced into
this very tough.
My dad and my mom were very fucking
brutal.
Half mexican,
half sicilian.
That's an I am.
And then my mom is sicilian,
like just the youngest sister in a with
all boys in the family.
Just a brutal lady who's like,
can't tell me how I tell you how many
times she said like,
fuck,
I'm just fuck them.
Like,
okay,
they're going to come know just a client
given her shit.
Like,
nah,
fuck them.
And they don't appreciate me.
Fuck you.
So was like that with us and then my
dad,
same thing,
they found each other for a reason
because they both have that attitude and
so I was there and then I was supposed
to be this eldest son taking over this
family business.
So when I met you in 1999,
you came up to my apartment which was in
telegraph.
It was a nice fucking apartment and I'm
like the opener with a great place.
And I lived.
I had a wet bar.
Remember?
Okay.
Can spot.
Yeah,
we smoked pot and watch old.
Oprah's oprah's whether she had big
hair,
huge hair,
no work done at all.
Just old oprah or just baked watching
fucking old oprah.
I hadn't even met,
like I had just met my wife at that
point.
And so this is.
Yes,
it's 1999.
And um,
I was working a regular job so I would
do shows on the weekend hosts the cops
or the punchline and go right back to
work.
And at one point I think I remember the
world started to collide.
Like I'm doing standup and I look out,
everybody's laughing except like three
dudes with their arms crossed.
I'm like,
oh shit.
Fire those fucking.
Yeah.
All the time dudes that you fired were
sitting in the audience said that you
started to make it into standard.
Like they go to see,
you know,
I don't think it happened and we found
me,
you know?
Wow.
They must've been fucking steaming.
Yeah.
Just like,
fuck that guy.
Everybody's laughing,
having a good set and look at just one
dude fucking scowling at me.
So creepy was that didn't mind.
Fuck you.
Yeah.
Know what?
I had such a good attitude at that
point.
I was like,
hey fellas.
Now it's a little weird.
Huh?
Did you talk about it?
Yeah.
Oh jesus.
I definitely acknowledged them and said
hello.
Like I knew their names and you didn't
say like,
hey,
I fired either until I can to everybody
in the entire room,
which I probably would do now.
Not experienced enough to handle it when
I met you.
How long had you been doing standup?
A year.
Oh wow,
that's crazy.
I just said a.
My 19th anniversary was on a tuesday.
Wow,
that's crazy.
First tuesday in may.
When did my first set went up in front
of like half homeless people in san
francisco at cobb's?
No,
at this place called the luggage store,
which was on market street.
Wow.
Tenderloin.
Full tenderloin.
Walked up.
I worked with you the first time I did
the old cops.
Yeah.
That place was great.
We got matched up because it was tom
sawyer used to like to like he would
make matches of he really pr.
I was.
He would pride himself in creating
lineups that people would.
People would go together and let me just
tell you something.
It worked once with you.
That's it.
All the other times were a fucking
disaster where it's like,
even when I was up there,
because I'd find it,
I'm like,
hey,
what's up?
He's like,
fuck,
is this guy just totally.
I can.
Yeah,
you put me with this fucking asshole.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
He put me with some,
you know,
there's some people that you think have
potential and then they just don't,
you know,
we've all,
we met guys like that.
I mean there's a few guys that I could
use to come up with used to come.
But I opened for you.
It was maddie kirsch.
Alright,
sure.
And then eddie
bravo fucking came on.
Well he'd come to hang out.
Ain't know what he was doing,
any standup,
but he was like a totally come to hang.
And then um,
I think it was down here that I met
brian and then brian started going
around.
What's you there?
Super early on?
Yeah.
That was when I was down in here in like
2004 and dunkin.
But that was the new cops as once they
started moving to the new spot in the
old one.
I think it was just mad.
Yeah.
Maddie kirsch.
Early days,
like maddie curse stopped doing standup
for a long time.
I think he's done.
I think he just completely stopped and
he stopped.
He started doing tv stuff.
He stopped doing standup and then he
went back to it again.
But I never saw them,
you know,
I think he's done.
Yeah,
I don't think you can dick around with
it.
I was with me and my buddies were
watching tim allen come back and you
know what I did?
He was such a nice guy and he watched
and he watched my sat and came up and
said bunch of stuff afterwards.
He was super cool to me and it was so
rough watching the set.
This was like,
he made all these santa claus movies and
he made all this shit and me and kevin
christie sent and about the.
I said,
you know what,
let's do something to this guy.
And we wrote them nine pages of jokes
and fucking just go here.
You go.
And handed them to him really?
And he goes,
thank you.
Oh my god.
And then we came back the next night and
he did a bunch of this shit and got an
applause break.
And one of my wife
felt so good.
So cool.
That's.
I saw him one night at the comedy store
when he hadn't done standup in for ever.
And he came back and he was doing a joke
about his ferrari breaking down.
A lot of people can relate to it and
listen to them.
Don't ever just don't do that.
I don't care if it's about a ferrari
breaking down.
Don't tell everybody you have a $250,000
car.
Well that's a big george carlin thing is
that when he got.
So we'll see an ied.
People going to the post office for him.
He's like,
I can't do the post office,
but now because I don't even go to the
fucking post office and I can't talk
about the bank because I never go to the
bank for myself.
I say like you got to do all your own
shit and just stay relatable.
It goes the other way too.
I was in New York and when I was out
there in the comic goes up and he was
like,
he goes,
you know what?
He's doing angel dust.
Like nobody knows.
Nobody knows what you're doing.
Fucking angel dust.
What are you talking about?
Talking about a niche audience.
Yeah,
totally.
So you know,
stand up like matt jumped out and it's
like,
I don't think you can jump out like it's
one of those things when you're 10,
but god damn you love it.
Like dana gould jumped out for a long
time and wrote for the simpsons came
back.
You can do it.
But you know,
arguably dana gould should have been a
huge superstar as a stand up comedian
using a san francisco guy who was like,
I listened to.
If you guys don't know that comic is,
I mean again,
go find it because so good.
So many voices,
so many characters.
So smart stories.
Like why met him in boston?
80 eight,
holy shit.
And he was already big then like he was
a headliner then and I'm doing really
well.
He was like rodney dangerfield,
young comedian,
special,
big,
right?
Like he was a,
he had a showtime special.
I remember that.
He had a showtime special before I moved
to la because I remember watching it and
it was really interesting was the way he
did.
It was like kind of unique to a shot.
it was unique and it was good.
It was really good and I was like,
this guy is going to be giant and I
figured it was going to be like from
their hbo specials,
from their giant theaters.
From there,
you know,
he was going to go the Brian Regan
route,
you know,
we're selling out all of these places,
but it just married the,
the woman who became ended up becoming
the president of hbo.
Done.
Good.
OnLy I have another thing.
One headshot per household.
Yes,
dude,
if you see like two,
I think tom segura and christina are the
ones that can pull it off to the only
ones.
Yeah.
I've not seen anyone else do this
successfully and I'm still standing back
like this on that one.
Blow up.
You got this.
You got it.
All right.
Well there was a kid on the daily show
that him and his wife audition for the
daily show at the same time and he got
it and she didn't.
Oh yeah.
In fun time in that house.
Not good.
Not good at all.
If somebody starts becoming super
popular and then the other person is
like,
oh,
what do I do?
Do I present that kirsch do like jump
out now or find other work and that's
also been a difficult thing with me.
So back to what we were talking about
and it's like,
so now I leave this parent's family
business and I come to la,
I could have again,
I could have been up there and miserable
fucking with firing people nonstop and
taking on other people's problems
because that's what I did is like if you
have a business or you work somewhere,
we'd employ everybody working there.
So You didn't have to deal with any of
the headaches.
But then I got all the headaches so I've
been chased like a.
I had a guy who was a time when knees,
like he sick this banner.
He was working in a doctor's office,
but on the weekends we found out he was
pretending he was the doctor.
Are you seeing patients?
His own patients?
But he was a physical therapy and uh,
um,
orthopedists office.
So I go in there and I've been doing
this awhile.
And again,
no,
just been in so many awkward situations.
Now I'm doing stand up and I'm even more
awkward situations and I just go up and
I go,
hey twon,
you know,
jig is up.
Go.
Today's your last day.
We found out what you're doing.
He grabs me,
puts me up against the wall,
he gets one of those physical therapy
sticks,
you know,
the big,
like the pole that you stretch with
behind your back and stuff.
And he has one of those cut In half and
he sticks it right up to my throat and
now I'm cool.
And so I go,
twan,
I got you got two choices here.
You're going to hit me with that stick
and I'm going to call the cops and I'm
going to charges.
you're going to go to jail.
Does that mean to be pissy?
Hit me with that fucking stick.
Or you can take the final check that's
in my breast pocket right here and walk
away.
What's it going to be?
and I'm held up against a wall by my
throat with the fucking stick in my
face.
And so had some crazy situation.
So what did you say to him?
You said the jig is up.
I know you're not a real doctor.
Yeah.
I go,
hey,
how you doing?
You shouldn't be here right now know
you're seeing response.
No,
this is not true.
These,
you know,
like in july we spoke english.
Yeah.
She's a physical therapist bangiNg
chicks to.
I have no idea.
I would like it to be that waY.
Yeah.
That's a better story if there's a way
to heal you.
So I didn't rush it.
Nurses running from me and just crazy
stories like why would they try to do to
you?
Uh,
well this russian nurse was in an
allergist office and she was giving
wrong doses to the kids and stuff of
shots.
Oh jeez.
All my documentation like these yellow
pads.
I goes,
there's um,
who you can see,
right?
I'm 22 years old.
you can see right here.
Then she tries to grab it.
Now it's a tug of war across a desk and
I don't know what the fuck is going on.
And um,
she takes off and runs down a haLlway
and I'm 22 and shit.
I fucking run down the hAllway
afterwards and she goes into a patient
room and didn't.
She locks the door and then I get the
door open and assist somebody unlock and
she's in there and she's talking to her
husband on the phone.
she goes through,
there is a mum here who's telling me
lies.
He's telling me like
I didn't want them to you,
these pregnant and the baby because of
these moms like that.
I'm going
totally
freaking out.
Oh my god.
I had a tea to teach.
A bunch of vietnamese people had to.
Shit.
There was one day I got a call,
got a call from this guy.
The issue.
Well they were her mungs.
Okay.
You know her mom is like this.
If you saw grand torino,
that movie with clint eastwood,
I think the h is silent,
I think.
Right?
The a h,
m o,
u n g,
and then there are people without a
land.
Yeah.
And then they go.
Came to san jose,
California to working assembly plants.
So they're in this cable assembly plant,
a plant called cable co.
That was a big client of ours and I got
a call from this really cool guy,
his name is chip,
chip bronc,
and he goes,
well you got to get down here,
you're not going to fucking believe it.
And I got a situation and I go,
what is it?
And it goes better.
you see
going into the bathroom.
Shit everywhere.
What?
Because they had never been used to
toilets.
So they were standing on the toilet
seats.
I found out that's what was going on.
They all had fake names,
like the names,
food,
cli,
but you can call me keith.
Hey keith fluidly.
Can you come here for a second?
Can I start you about this shit
everywhere.
Like on the ground?
Yeah,
they were missing.
So toilet seat is not meant to fucking
hold you up.
So they're waddling up there standing on
the standing on the toilet.
So they were just used to like shitting
and shitting and holes.
Oh my god,
they're lucky,
you know,
in the woods or whatever.
So,
so lucky.
Not lucky where they hold them forever.
So yeah,
just backed up his becomes a brick.
Yeah.
So,
um,
anyway,
I gathered everybody around,
I just appointed a bathroom monitor and
oh my god,
bathroom monitors.
So I had one of the guys who was the
supervisor,
I had a clipboard,
I put a lock on the bathroom door and
then.
so you become this corporate fixer.
That's what I was doing and I always
wanted to do standup comedy.
I love standup comedy.
I grew up in the city which is listening
to the comedians on the radio and all
the great comics was to comics who lived
on my block.
And so I love lived on your block.
Mike pritchard and michael.
Me and two great comics.
Mike pritchard,
one the first san francisco comedy
competition.
And robin williams looked up to him.
He was like robin williams.
That was his idol and he was on my
block.
And you don't money hoffman.
Yeah,
money.
Hoffman.
I'll be eight years old on my bike and
I'd ride down the block and money.
Hoffman and mike pritchard used to put
their tee shirts over their heads.
You know how you can do with just the,
the whole face pops out of the hole.
And they used to pretend they were the
California raisin guys.
You guys are hilarious.
This is amazing.
They lived on your block on my block.
And I remember.
Where's pritchard now?
I think he's a motivational speaker.
is still up in the bay area.
Lead lives in marin.
He came To the last night at cobb's
comedy club in that little spot.
Why you stopped doing standup?
I just speaks.
Wow.
Weird.
Yeah.
So,
um,
well,
you know,
that's another tempting thing for me too
is because I do a ton of corporate
standup,
I get you can get paid,
you know,
five figures to deep five figures to
speak at 3:30 PM and do stand up at a
thing and you know,
if your standup career,
like you're in a good,
amazing spot because people come to see
you.
Like I'm still at the stage where I go
out and 40 percent other people,
they're come to cv and it's a weird
cross section of people who love stand
up or you know,
heard me,
you heard me on burt's podcasts or your
podcast,
you know,
whaTever.
And then it's a weird cross section,
a daily show people and then sitcom
people and then,
you know what I mean?
It's like this weird crowd coming
together.
and then it's um,
it's people like comedy.
It said stan hope bit people.
How many people came here to see me and,
and when many people came here to see
comedy.
Yeah.
And he's like,
music isn't like that.
And so for me to do a corporate gig and
pay get paid double gazillion,
you know,
like a lot of money is fucking tempting
to switch over to that side.
So I could see why people do that.
That's what jay leno did.
You just get paid 250 grand and that's
why he doesn't put out any content.
Jay.
Oh.
Doesn't have the same act he has.
No,
he has no body of Work.
Like he had a showtime special that he
did that I saw in the nineties and I'm
pretty sure other than his tonight show
monologues,
which of course has numerous.
I think that's the last stand up.
Did he ever put out as far as like a,
like a full act?
Talk to him about it.
yeah.
He's kind of weird philosophy about it.
I did random,
randomly got a phone call to present him
with his mark twain award at the kennedy
center.
Oh wow.
It was me fucking seinfeld,
jimmy fallon,
seTh meyers.
I'm like crazy people.
It's,
you know,
wanda sykes and I had no business being
there.
Chelsea handler was doing whatever,
just like an all stars and I'd never met
him before and I think they just wanted
to color it up,
but I'm going to say yes because it's
fucking kennedy center and super super
cool.
And I got there and I meet them for the
first time and then my act was like,
what are you doing?
Like you have $250,000,000 or something
like that.
And You still,
every sunday you go to the comedy magic
club,
you don't turn over your act.
You got separate comedy,
money in tv,
money in this car collection.
I go,
what,
what do you like?
Just chill out,
man.
Yeah.
And uh,
I,
can you give me the fucking $4,000,000?
You never see me again?
And it goes sold from the balcony and
then we had a long conversation about it
afterwards,
which was super weird and talked about
that exact same thing that you just
discussed is that he has an act that he
wants to keep doing and if it never
appears on tv,
you've got to go see him to see it.
But people get mad when they see him
twice.
Oh yeah.
Like uh,
he was in edmonton.
He did the river cree and then he did it
again a year later and he did the same
act.
And uh,
the people that were mad.
Well that's just,
I mean,
for,
for those old school guys,
that's how you did it.
I mean,
it's not a no knock against him.
That's how everybody did it.
It can't skills guys and vaudeville,
they build.
Those guys would do the same act for 10
years.
And it was also,
you could do other people's asks.
Yes.
Right.
Yeah,
they just did.
They have did that,
you know,
they will social media when the
abbott and costello did who's on first
on tv 20 other guys were pissed because
they also did that exact same bit.
Really?
Yeah.
And they're like,
thanks a lot fellas.
I could never fucking do that thing.
And so who's on first?
Wasn't an abbott and costello original.
Was there 20 other duets doing that
exact same fucking material?
Wow.
Yeah.
So now let's complete jay leno courses
carrying that.
You're pissed.
When I started in san francisco is great
guy.
Jimmy cornet who ran the punchline,
we were talking about other people
coming through and not changing their
act and he goes,
dude,
you need a new 20 minutes.
At least every time we come through here
people are going to be pissed.
They want to see the hits.
And this would obviously would say we go
see the stones,
you want to see brown sugar,
but you got to mix in some fucking new
shit every once in a while to comments
or feel like they less want to see the
hits more than anything with music.
Like they actually just want to see the
hits,
like if you go to see the stones,
they don't want to hear any new stones
shifts once satisfaction.
But if you go to see bird,
you want to see all this new stuff.
Yeah.
You're familiar to.
You saw his last netflix.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
So that keeps us creative.
It keeps you fresh.
You have to constantly be hustling.
Totally.
Yeah.
It's um,
that's what I say when I saw you the
other night when you did that atc show.
You had that funny.
No vagina bit.
Thanks man.
That was because again,
and that's another thing,
it's like you grow up in san francisco
when you become like,
you see guys coming through and I
watched,
I went to see everybody.
So I lived in between comms and the
punchline and that's where I did.
If you,
you know,
outliers 10,000 hours.
Yeah.
Walk to the cops.
I know for.
I did this for maybe 13 months straight
almost every single night I walked the
comps.
Then I'd walk to the punchline and I saw
every single act saw damon wayans.
Carlos mitzia is scott,
you know,
for kids in the hall.
What's his face?
got to thompson said just anybody who
would come through.
I go see,
I can see every single night and I want
you to good ones.
I took something from everybody,
but then I sort of watched people come
through a second time and not change
anything.
I stopped to watch features that were
better than the headliner and feature,
you know,
the conversation over in the corner and
fucking just watching it all and it just
again,
you see what people are doing and how
much work people put into this.
It's a tremendous amount of work,
but to do the bits also.
And that's another thing is like san
francisco,
you wouldn't put hacky comics up.
Right?
They wouldn't get to play there.
Sawyer wouldn't fucking work here
for good reason.
I really appreciated that about him.
It's one of the reasons whY I was
willing to go back and do his clubs so
many times.
Yeah.
SO again,
that's when you come to la and you're
like,
what the fuck is this?
There's some of that like what we were
talking about,
we don't need to name any names,
but that one person who just as a bunch
of shit and says it fast and then you're
like,
okay,
what?
What are you doing?
You're ruining the night.
There's a lot of tricks,
tricks you're saying a bunch of pop
culture references and a bunch of shit,
but there's no like so hard to be
judgmental about someone else's craft or
art,
but there's times when you know whether
someone is actually trying to work
something out or whether they're trying
to trick the audience too.
There's a bunch of stuff You guys that
you can do to elicit laughter and you
can memorize a huge string.
It's called.
Yeah,
it's a string and you can just fucking
rattled some done and then they got a
big applause.
Bah ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba.
What?
I did,
what I did after that.
What did you do this.
I don't want to be like this.
I just want to read,
write and jack reacher on my deck and
fucking chill out and I bought that fga
62 land cruiser and I want to fucking
just,
I want to get a little trailer behind
that.
I want to go to big sur with my wife's
go chill out by the ocean.
Chill out.
Yeah.
I want to be that guy,
but you're not,
but I'm not.
I'm not.
I really want to be.
Anyway,
I followed that.
Yeah.
One comic we're talking about and I
walked out and I go,
how bad it I go,
name.
I go,
what was that last applause?
Break all about the offer to donate some
money to charity.
Just for no reason.
You shouldn't have done it.
Just shouldn't talk shit.
well,
I think the only time you should talk to
is when someone's doing something
negative.
Like stealing.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean we've all been there before.
When you see someone go up and you go,
okay,
that's not even your act.
Yeah.
It happens less now than ever before.
Don't think this is like the cleanest
time for comedy as far as like,
you're still hear little stories pop up
here and there,
but I think it's also now it's
subjective and there's lunch.
So much standup.
I was thinking like I have this hour
special coming out,
um,
this weekend on showtime and I think
talking to somebody about it and there's
a special coming out like every fucking
two days.
Yeah,
they're not that special anymore or not,
but it's a great time for content.
Like if you want to see comedy,
like you go on netflix or showtime or
cso or any of these different providers
to cecil.
If I could stand then stand up special.
And I watched the and mentioned it as
they go.
The doug stan hope special on.
So if you have not seen this,
I feel like is one of the best things
I've ever seen.
And I walked in to the comedy club and
he saw punchline for the very first time
and I saw arch barker onstage kill just,
he's a great comic.
He's just fucking murdered.
And I had the same feeling that when I
watched that doug stanhope special,
oh,
just I haven't seen it.
I need to see it,
my god,
the bills just again.
And it's like next level shit that I
hope people can really appreciate the
call backs and the intricacies of this
Whole thing and the story in somebody
who's on something and saying
something like.
But doug did two of them in his
hometown.
He did them bolt in bisbee,
right?
Yeah.
This is the one that was shot in bisbee
by a head again.
You know,
it's just.
I love the fact that he's doing that.
like we talked about it a couple of
years ago is I can park in my town.
I just got to fucking see these people
at the safe way.
And then apparently he just said,
fuck it,
why not?
Why can't I do it in my town?
And then eventually his town stopped
being the talent was.
And as a bunch of people who moved there
because they know doug lives there.
Oh dude.
First of all,
he's a real estate mogul.
He bought everY house that comes up.
They're all like $30,000.
He just buys it.
He's just buying houses.
So he owns like,
I think you want six or seven houses in
town.
This is with jack reacher novel where
he's going to own the town.
Good time.
Fuck dude.
If I got divorced,
I thought I'd seriously consider moving
there.
There's already a house I'm looking at.
It's a cave.
No way to indicate when it's Built into
a cake.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Now I can't buy it because people know
they'll show up at my door.
But uh,
he,
uh,
so many people move to bit.
He used to give out his address and say,
come into my superbowl party.
So people would come from all over the
world to his fucKing superbowl party.
And it was ridiculous.
It'd be 500 people that he didn't know
at his house for a superbowl party.
So he stopped doing that.
He rescinded the invitation.
That's what me and bert were talking
about is doing a thing called a caravan
comedy tour and getting a bunch of rvs
and our trucks and trailers and just
going a bunch of guys because also
sudden it's like just a special kind of
comic.
You're,
you're one of those comics.
It's like you have give kids,
you have a family of life,
you have stuff outside of standup,
you know,
sake to get those guys together.
And bert is one of those,
you know,
we're like,
you have a couple kids and like get the
kids and the wives,
it takes a lot to be a comedian wife and
they all have that in common,
so I'm sure everyone would get along
great because they have to deal with us
and so the wives and the kids,
everybody in rv and then we all go out
and do shows and then everybody gets to
go to the grand canyon,
the next
bad idea,
bad idea.
And then duncan,
we talked about dunkin doesn't have any
kids.
I know,
but he's got a dog will be still be fun
on the road.
Yeah,
that's a great idea man.
So you know,
I just wanted an excuse to buy one of
those airstreams.
Totally.
I just think they look bad ass.
Well I build upon your fj 62.
Oh my god.
I don't think I haven't been.
I got business cards.
I'm looking at.
There's a place called off the grid
rentals and just to test out,
but it's too small.
It's like this teardrop.
It's a four by 14.
So you can put a rooftop tent on top of
it.
Has the ladder that goes up.
Yeah.
And then I could just have everybody.
I'm thinking I want a little bit more
surreal one.
Well I've been going to the differences.
Sports mobile,
if you go to sportsman will bill.com,
which is fucking dirt.
They've been doing it for a long time
but you can get one of those dodge
sprinter vans,
a diesel truck down
and get that four by four it out and
just go.
And then you could still tell some
stuff.
So there's this company called fuck it.
What is the company called?
There's aN expedition vehicle that they
take and they take like a ford f 2:50
and then they put this thing on top of
the roof,
lIke the like above the front cab.
It goes up and then back know exactly
what you're saying.
It's got solar power and a generator and
you can live in those fucking things.
It's all ready to rock.
There's a rock climber guys.
Look at that fucking thing.
Jesus christ.
Oh my god.
I'm in love with a rooftop tent.
Yeah,
and will they do that too?
They take vans and there's a company
called u joint off road.
They take a van like that.
They remove the natural suspension or
suspension that comes with it and put a
full on dual solid axle.
Four wheel drive suspension setup in.
Uh huh.
And you could just drive that
motherfucker xmmobile.com and take a
look at this now because this is what
they used to do and they're still doing
with some of these.
The vans Will do this.
That looks amazing words.
But if you look at what they're doing
with the mercedes and the dodge
sprinter,
that's when it just goes up to a whole
nother level.
Downsize other sites down.
Oh yeah.
But you can see soMe of them.
Yeah.
Like it just fucking.
I like.
Yep.
I like it.
I have those same ideas,
but I do go on these trips for hunting
where I go out in the woods five,
six days at a time and most of the time
there's no cell phone service.
I just did bordaiN,
uh,
with the crew that you guys shot with in
Montana.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
What'd you do?
I did his uh,
no reservation.
Yeah.
Well it's called,
um,
what is it called now?
Parts and parts unknown.
Yeah.
Where'd you go?
What'd you do?
We just say it was mexican food down on
of street.
Oh,
nice.
Nice.
Yeah,
we went bird hunting in Montana.
It was fun.
So interesting that,
that guy's still goes hard.
Yeah.
Hard.
Like I'm throwing them back.
We got so high I thought I could feel
the earth benning will.
He had just come from.
He was super late.
I got drunk.
If you watch this parts unknown,
I'm fucking wasted
up.
People are like,
why is that magical?
His eyes closed kind of super drunk.
He was four hours late and I just went
to bars with that crew while we were
waiting for him because he got a tattoo
and then he showed up super late and
then we ate to ketos and by the time he
got there I was just trashed.
I'm the biggest lightweight of all time.
It really is true.
I did a show with you had the comedy
magic club.
We walked around the corner and got
baked with red band and then I went back
in and I had to apologize to your
audience.
I go,
I've been so busy,
been able to get back like I used to and
it just fucking snuck up on me.
I don't know what the fuck is going on.
Where you can stock up.
You could sneak up on you.
Easy today.
Yeah,
and like people are productive.
Doug benson is A producTive
motherfuCker.
He gets a lot done.
I can't speak.
I'll just leave that there.
Yeah,
I get it.
I mean,
some people are much more comfortable
with joey.
Joey diaz is constantly in that state.
I saw him who senT me a picture of it.
If it was a.
Somebody showed me something that he was
in the noodles.
Big gummy bear,
dude,
that has 3000,
300 milligrams milligrams of thc in that
thing and you'd like chop the head off
and he does that all the time that he
stopped doing that though,
by the way,
joe.
He stopped.
He backed off the edibles.
Oh really?
Yeah,
just tax.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I can't,
I have such.
I'm been waking.
I just went to the doctor.
I a little bit of a health scare and
this is two days ago,
uh,
because I've been waking up in the
middle of the night out of breath.
Yeah.
Oh,
you probably have sleep apnea at that or
I get a sleep study that's being done
and then I'm just saying I have anxiety
and we definitely have anxiety.
Yeah,
a lot of it.
You ever thought about doing like yoga
or anything?
Um,
I try to go to the gym.
I go to the gYm every morning,
but I don't like I need to meditate and
people have talked to me about
transcendental meditation and stuff like
that that I need to settle the fuck
down.
YeAh,
they.
But you know that you have this thing
and you're not doing anything.
I'm not doing anything about it.
And the doctor said that this is good.
now you're finally being compelled to
talk about it with Somebody that is a
problem and you feel like you're angry
at yourself for being so anxious.
Because if I go to the airport with my
wife and kidS,
I could feel it.
I feel my anxiety.
I feel myself freaking the fuck out.
Wow.
When you freak out,
like what's the thought?
What are you worried about?
We got to get through and everybody
slowing us down.
I go early.
I know that's what I started doing it.
That's why I'm like trying to prepare
myself was so huge.
Just leave an hour earlier than you need
to and you don't give a shit and I still
look at my wife from like the last
couple of times,
like doing pretty good.
I'm working on it.
It's weird.
It seems like maybe you were set up for
this from like your early career,
like this,
like tension,
you know,
and then the desire for success like to
be a successful comic is a lot of
hustling and does a lot of life.
You've got to fuckIng,
you gotta be on your point.
You got to be on your game.
He had a look around,
go,
go.
And now with atc again,
I feel so much responsibility for all
these comics and things.
So we have 50 podcasts.
We have 50 live comedian.
That thing down for sure.
I tried.
That'S another thing where you getting
calls.
I did 20 percent at least.
Right?
Everybody's like,
okay,
here's,
here's a perfect fucking example.
Like ian edwards has a podcast called
soccer comic.
I'm not going to.
I love ian edwards to death.
Right?
[inaudible].
He's on that note.
I don't care for people listening that
fucking show.
He's on that network.
I don't.
Okay.
I don't give a shit.
Yeah.
I feel the same way and so I don't care
about the numbers as much as I believe
in the comics,
likE there's two comedians,
michael,
constant,
mike and chris fairbanks that I want to
start making tv like they're not on tv.
Costs is a funny dude.
This is a funny motherfucker and I have
a great story with costa.
So um,
this is how we met me and bill burr
first comes to
comedy store,
sees me,
we become friendly,
then sees me onstage,
did some bit about how my wife's half
korean,
half greek and I go,
I might add this korean mother in law
and I don't do any jokes about her
because then I'd be doing margaret cho's
jay,
I act and who wants that
shithead
fucking.
He loves it and I can't.
That's fucking hilarious.
We go now I'm at the point in la,
you guys like I'm doing spots,
I'm not doing anything else.
And so I'm working on these tv shows as
much as I can,
but when I'm not,
I'm at the comedy store two cents.
Then I go to the laugh factory,
then I go to the improv.
I'm doing that triangle and I'm hitting
them all and I had the ice house,
like I'm going everywhere.
I'M a guy who's doing like 12 sets a
week and this is from 2004 until I get
the daily show,
pretty much like this is a good solid
six or seven years of just fucking going
and then go to the improv and bill
again.
New I go,
let's go to the improv.
It's fucking go down there.
and so he jumps in my car.
We drove down to the improv.
It's a show that they're doing where
they show a sketch comedy video and then
they bring up a standup and then they
show a sketch comedy video and a stand
up and my cost as the host.
So I go up in between these sets and I
look at them and I go,
heY,
do you know if they're going to show
another video?
Are they going to bring me up?
And then he responds,
I forget what he says,
but then he goes up on stage and he
goes,
okay,
this next comedian is,
um,
I guess it's al magic guy.
If You want me to pronounce your name
right,
you got to come introduce yourself to me
before the shit.
I can'T be expected to this.
I don't know if it's a guy or a girl and
I'm on the side losing it and I go,
fuck you.
And he goes,
what?
I go,
you heard me fuck this room full of
asian night or something.
Like there's all these chinese people
there.
And so I go,
everybody turns and I go,
you heard me?
Fuck you.
I go do Your job.
I introduced myself to you like,
just get the fuck off stage.
And I go,
what?
Because he's like,
I don't know if it's a guy or a girl.
Who are you going to go,
dude,
you're the fucking host.
Figure it out,
right asshole.
So I walk up and I proceed to just lay
into him.
Just fucking 15 minutes are about the
guy or girl,
you're the host.
It's all you have one fucking job to do.
Bills hunched over,
laughing on the side.
we're going to.
all the comics in the back are just.
See there's tables In the back or on the
floor.
And it's the echo,
it's fucking asian night.
This is the worst crowd scenes that
atlanta like just going crazy and I
can't help it.
Again,
if anyone's listening to this guy's an
asshole,
I don't want to be.
I want to do that.
right.
It just came out compelled
uncontrollable fucking burst of fucking
telling people this asshole continuous.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
And I could've,
I could've gone.
I'm right here.
Sorry about that.
Magical,
magical.
no problem.
Just bring me up.
Yeah.
But that puts you in a bad position.
You go up there like sort of.
Yeah.
Like they can submitting.
It's willie barcelona had those storIes
about like headbutting somebody in the
hallway because they brought up charles
fleischer instead of him.
You know,
he will.
It's crazy.
Well,
yeah,
that's a whole nother thing.
Like,
I think I told that story last time I
was on his podcast were I told him to
fuck off and he's an east la street
fighter.
So I.
Yeah,
it doesn't matter.
I don't think when I see red they
fucking started telling everybody,
fuck you.
So anyway,
I'm being my costa.
Very good friends.
To this day I came up,
I mean,
I see the error of my ways right away
and I go,
apologize and go deal.
Can't control It.
I'm sorry.
I see crazy shit people.
And so again,
when you and I have never had a
weirdness,
weird moment happens with very few
people,
but when it does,
when you feel slighted.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I've never slighted you like,
and if you.
No,
no you haven't.
Yeah.
But yeah.
I don't know.
Again,
I want to just,
just to,
uh,
consider.
I know that feeling though.
There's a feeling,
especially like the anxiety before
you're performing,
you're,
you're ready to go.
And then someone that you feel lIke
someone's fucking with you and you're
like,
oh,
okay.
I've had that happen before where a host
will purposely say some dickie things
about you thinking they're going to chop
down your set.
I've done the same thing.
I just go after him.
Upset.
Totally.
Yeah.
Um,
who's in brendan schaub told me the
stories like he to people because,
you know,
he's a big guy and a stand up new
standards and somebody went up on stage
at the improv and he said,
um,
he said,
who the fuck is that guy?
Like,
you can't be that handsome fucking
started just tearing into them for being
like,
this isn't a fighter too for you.
Yeah.
Well those erik griffin was it?
Yeah,
he was just fucking around.
it was just like,
that's what you say,
you know,
the guy
goes up and he does stand up and he's
got this perfect haircut and you're
like,
hey,
fuck you.
You know,
eric goes up with the spare tire rod is
waste is a big jolly guy fuck out of
here with this fatty with glasses and a
mustache mustache.
So he looks like he puts on the glasses
and mustache together today.
It's like when he was doing that,
I was trying to tell brendan,
I go,
dude,
that's what we do.
I go,
you got to understand that like you go
up,
you do your set,
the guys can shit on you.
You know what I mean?
That's like I would have shit on youtube
probably.
Especially in New York,
same thing.
Oh,
you fucking whore in New York anymore.
If you don't do two or three minutes of
what's going on in the room and what
just happened,
you're going to have his shitty set like
that's I would.
That's what I learned right away.
You have to Be like,
you know,
start of hugging,
hold everyone's attention and just start
launching into material to comment on
what's happening.
You know what that is from.
I noticed that too when I lived in New
York,
I was like this because the crowds are
small and the stage is small.
It's way more intimate experience.
It's like the belly room,
you know?
The belly room is a totally different
experience in the or,
which is a totally different experience
in the main room.
It's one of the beautiful things about
doing the hat trick of the comedy store.
if you do all three rooms in a night,
you get to feel the different.
Like the belly room is so much more
intimate and so much more intense
because there's only 70 people in the
room and they're jammed in there and
they're right in front of you.
And that's like in New York room.
so I'm doing that.
That show on showtime about standup
comedy.
I'm dying up here.
You get to meet that guy in the back.
That's helping me.
He's making that show.
And we were talking about the belly room
and interviewing people about that just
to figure it out.
And that used to be,
it was called a billy room because it
was for women.
And then like at pregnant women,
you know,
like a womb.
Mitsui literally thought of it as a
comedy womb.
Yep.
Yeah.
And then they used to put overflow.
So if richard pryor,
somebody huge was in the main room,
they put all the overflow up in the
belly room and then a comic would be on
stage and they'd come in if like a table
opened up,
they'd go mid,
mid act thompson party for like you,
you're doing stand up onstage.
And the waItress would come in and go at
the thompson's here and then the
thompson's ever sitting in the front and
they just get up and walk out and go to
see richard pryor
so that place,
you know.
And then I worked on that with erik
griffin so I didn't really know him that
well before and hilarious just fucking
fucks with people nonstop.
so of course he was the guy that said
that shit,
but he's a great dude.
He's a nice guy.
He's not doing it because he's an
asshole.
He's just being silly.
That's what I was trying to tell
brendan.
He's like,
you wouldn't hit me hard bro.
And I'm like,
that's what we do.
You like brendan's new to this whole
world,
you know,
because he started out doing podcasts.
He's a funnY guy.
And then he started doing these live
podcasts with cal and then they would do
sort of like a little sketch,
like a comedy routine.
and then he would do a few minutes on
his own just doing like kind of standup,
like telling his story.
And he's funny.
He says he has some funny ideas.
So now he's doing sets like on a regular
basis and then he's doing sets in front
of people don't know which is the right
way to do it.
Totally.
The bad things that people do is they
only do their own crowd over and over
and over again.
Not smart.
You got to go out and do those shows
that I was trying to.
Like when you start doing standup
comedy,
you invite all your friends out and it
takes you three sets to figure out,
oh shit,
I better stop inviting my friends that
do it.
Well and not only that,
but if you invite your friends out and
they're a significant part of the
audience,
they've already seen your jokes.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's just goes bad right away and you're
like,
oh,
I want to make strangers laugh.
I want to make a complete strangers like
and if I can do that and it just makes
you a better comic.
I got a bunch of shit and we were
talking about this building.
I got a bunch of shit for fucking
heckling.
Steevo an attitude,
heckle them in the audience,
the improv.
I was on stage,
I told the story,
I said,
I don't again,
I don't want to be this guy.
I really don't.
You don't understand that it is a
problem and I'm trying to.
I'm going to go to a cognitive
behavioral.
This what the doctor prescribed me is
cognitive behavioral specialists is
gonna stop me from doing shit like this.
ReallY?
Yeah.
But,
uh,
I said,
I don't feel bad,
that bad event,
this.
I said,
um,
he was in the audience and I said,
alriGht,
I go,
I don't want to care about standup this
much.
I really don't.
I'm so passionate about this.
you guys don't fucking understand.
Like I take so and so stole this joke
and stole that joke and I go,
I just got to come to grips with the
fact that what I feel like is my life's
calling is somebody else's last resort.
And then,
because I told you about like dustin
diamond to stand up,
I go fucking,
uh,
you know,
skippy from family times does stand up
like,
and then people don't even know what
that is anymore.
I know.
Does he still do it?
Skippy?
Yeah,
I think so.
That's the diamond was in jail and stab
somebody.
Yeah.
Yeah,
tell he was doing stand up.
He was lIke a family ties sort of ended.
He was doing standup when I was an open
mic or I was just starting out and he
was headlining in these places and
that's,
you know,
he had this big smile,
skippy from family ties and he just
would go on the road,
but I never heard from him again.
Yeah,
I wonder what that guy's doing.
There's kind of at some point the
audience just goes away and then people
stopped booking you and then you have to
go away.
I guess.
What do you do a job?
I guess?
Hopefully you invested your money
properly and some real estate.
Skippy.
Skippy is just a real estate baron Who
talks me down and has callen has talked
me down a couple of tImes.
He's like,
no,
just relax.
He's a nice guy.
Don't worry about it counts as a calm
guy.
Yeah.
But you know,
the thing is like it is your life
calling and for some people it isn't.
Some people,
it's like something that came along
after they had been doing a bunch of
other stuff,
but that's okay.
Yeah,
whatever.
Who cares?
There's an audience for a lot of people
will say like,
that guy's not really comic.
Like if you're doing stand up your comic
and although most of them don't ever
become comics,
you respect.
It's not like it's outside the realm of
possibility that you could do it or I
could do it.
How come they can't do it?
Somebody said this about carrot top,
like that fucker carried around say what
you will.
But that fucking carried around that bag
fucking time.
Not only that,
he,
he monopolize that genre.
That was a legit genre.
When we started out.
You remember like there were prop
comics.
I'm buddies with rusty.
Rusty do.
It was a problem.
Yeah,
but there's no prop comics anymore.
that's and carrot top.
He killed the genre.
Wow.
Dude.
When I first started in 88,
there was a.
you would have a prop comic on every
other show.
Three or four shows.
You do three or four shows.
One of those shows.
How would have a prop comic con it now?
They don't exist anymore,
so I really feel like in this.
I'm dying up here.
We did a good job of bringing all that
stuff back and this is nice.
Set.
Nineteen,
73 weekend on a ventriloquist is.
I can't Wait for you to see the show.
The other thing,
there's no more.
Ventral goes.
Who killed that?
I'm probably dual.
Jeff dunham.
Yes.
He owns it.
And then there was.
You saw otto and george.
I worked with auto times many times.
We did prom shows together in New York.
Oh my god.
Tell me.
People don't know what auto in Georgia,
so you can.
Maybe you can explain it as you worked
with them because I saw the puppet would
say the most vicious,
vile,
racist shit and then he would go,
I can't believe you're saying that.
And you'd go,
hey,
look at that fucking ladies.
Yeah.
It was just walking the entire room.
He would say ruthless,
ruthless shit.
He was a great guy to dead.
Yeah.
He died and I'm a sawyer.
Had them in that small room and we
watched tourist after tours walkaway and
tom looked at me and the rest of the
comics who again,
or just hunched over on the floor and he
goes,
I'm losing money this weekend guys,
but this is for us.
That's great.
yeah,
and his act was ridiculous.
We did a.
We did jersey shore shows for this guy.
Pop gonzo.
We did a.
I did a lot of shows with auto.
They go looking for horse and crack.
Oh,
he would go.
He would go off.
Yeah,
he would get crazy here.
We get crazy.
You have through sending.
So we ended up with ventriloquist in the
show.
Kind of like the petty fights.
Like I get to write on it,
so I got to incorporate all my fucking
weirdness in there and like a petty
bullshit.
Bad intro.
Fuck you.
Well you guys also got 19 seventies
wardrobe and hair,
which is fucking bad ass.
I saw some photos of it.
my daughter walked out to me and I'm
onset.
Didn't say anything about my hair.
I'm not going to biggest mustache you.
I'll post a picture of just dragging
them.
I think it's on,
it's online.
Jamie could probably find it.
Um,
huge real mustache.
Big side burns and that our mind.
And then this wig,
my daughter walks up,
she goes,
why are you wearing a towel?
Terry?
Cloth
towels.
They bother.
Why is your shirt made out of a towel?
I don't understand.
As kids growing up,
how were your kids who had grown up with
like do they know stand up comic debt?
Like they're figuring it out?
Yeah.
I brought my uh,
living in New York,
brought practicing for a comedy central
special that I don't think one person
saw and I go an hour half hour.
When did you do it?
I did in 2014.
Two thousand 13 or something that gave
you,
once you started doing the daily show,
early show special came out and how many
times they were having crying.
Just fuckIng midnight on a friday.
Those motherfuckers you burn a special
with them.
Yeah,
it's a problem.
Well,
you know what?
And then they're like,
but you can catch It online at comedy
central.
Dr. But he companies going there,
no one is going there,
it's not happening to them to do,
to netflix,
sell them to netflix or have a
billboard,
really have a campaIgn that says dave
attell,
jim gaffigan,
jill rogue,
like all these names of just every comic
that you love and watch all available
here.
Two dollars.
Like,
you know,
what are some like just not going to do
that because no one's going to do it.
They're not like you have to have
something on a platform that people are
already used to.
Cecil,
you have amazon,
you have netflix and you know,
like apple,
that's it.
No one else is going anywhere else.
It's just not going to happen.
Yeah.
It's too easy to do those things.
So anyway,
to be burned that special.
Anyway.
So,
uh,
I am practicing for that.
I go up to rochester,
New York,
bring my wife and kids with me and we
stay in a holiday inn and suites and
this is a six year old little girl,
goes over to the curtains,
opens them up,
and she goes,
I'm,
why am I looking at the parking lot?
I go,
everybody gather around.
ThIs is the road.
Okay,
that's what I do.
This is what daddy does,
so when you think I'm having a great
time flying around,
it really gets sad.
We're going to fight a businessman for a
waffle tomorrow morning.
Everybody shut up
those rochester road gigs.
Rough like those spots where people
don't necessarily want to go.
Albany.
Rochester,
well yeah.
It was a bar.
It is attached to a country western bar
called daisy dukes.
Oh,
jesus looked that up.
It a place in in youngstown,
Ohio that I did that was a to a disco
and there was a back door and every time
the back door would open up,
like when people would go to the
bathroom here
and the door would slowly close.
Okay.
So it was rough.
I did this place,
laughs in kirkland,
Washington,
and I go there and I'm doing this again
if you want.
She's like longer stories,
tangents,
characters,
shit like that.
For the most part,
like my closer is 25 minutes long and
this special.
It starts wIth this 2014.
No,
this is the one I'm doing right now that
comes down to,
thIs comes out this week and 20 minutes
long,
so it's this big long fucking bit that
I've been working on forever about
revenge and my anger.
I did see food revenge.
I shrimped the place.
That's what it's called.
Shrimp in an easy.
So I'm a fucking.
Just a mess and I'm.
Well I forgot I just got off track.
I forgot what I was talking about.
The road open up the parking lot,
fighting someone over a waterfall.
Kirkland,
Washington so,
so at kirkland hand a big long in the
middle of a big long story and they
bring out these trays that have neon
lights around them with jello shots on
him and they and they and everybody in
the entire audience looks at these trays
there.
They look like ufo was.
They got jello shots on him and I go,
ladies and gentlemen,
we're going to interrupt.
Is a crafted a bit that took me fIve
years to master to bring you in.
Yeah.
Who wants a jello shot?
Lets everybody do jello shots.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Jello shot time.
and I just started fucking selling the
shit out of jello shots as a bit because
I'm like,
this guy fucked up like this.
I need everyone concentrating.
Ideal is printing it out.
The owner and the waitresses are
bringing out these trays.
Just ufo trays.
The jello shots at a comedy club at a
comedy club.
Lose every single person in the
audience.
It's A standard thing.
They do,
I guess.
So I just went with it and what they do
at the end of the night to wrap up,
there's just a big push in the night.
We're going to get some extra dollars in
our coffers.
Believe it was happening.
I was shocked at the time and then the
owner comes up like I was serious.
And he goes,
holy shit.
He goes,
we sold out of jello shots.
You were amazing.
That was unbelievable.
And then I walk into the next night
who's got more jello shots?
I mean the kitchen is filled with them
and those jello shots come out.
And I don't say a thing.
Siri.
I thought we were a business together.
We had a good thing going on.
I don't know if you know this because he
didn't mention he didn't mention the
jello shots.
What are you doing?
I go,
yeah,
I really,
I don't know if you could tell by really
hate the fucking jello shots like I go.
It was just,
it was horrible.
You should not be selling them.
I don't know.
It's a huge distraction.
What did he say?
It was just to teach you a lesson.
Like a fucking sell any jello shots now.
You weren't pushing them?
No.
Zero.
so he just had a huge,
like he should probably explained that
to him.
Yeah,
on the first night and then he would
have got it,
but he probably still would have sold
them anyway.
He made money and he was a nice guy and
it was nice,
like it was just like it.
I don't know man,
like I can't.
It's hard for me to do.
And again,
if you have people coming out that know
you and you're going out to see
something in you like collectively or
group of people that love an individual
comic,
it's a great place to be.
But again,
if you're up there winning over 60
percent of the audience,
not good,
but rather just go hang out at the
store.
Well,
it's good to do the road though because
like you can.
I think like every time you do a set in
a new place,
you got a new experience,
a new vibe,
a new feel,
new crowds.
New I like.
I think places also have like a
different personality.
Like I feel like portland,
Oregon has a different personality than
a lot of places.
Like you go up to portland and feels
different,
the audience feels different and then
you go to austin,
Texas different feeling like a little
lighter.
They're little lighter,
a little more fun.
It's more silly.
I like doing shows in Canada,
in toronto.
One of the best sets I've ever had my
entire fucking life.
Toronto,
vancouver is fun for me to go to.
Canadians are just great audiences.
I don't know what it is to just.
It's loose.
They're not uptight about 20 percent
less douchebags.
Really?
Yeah.
That's my theory about Canada.
They have 20 percent less douche bags
and it must be what it is.
There's aLways fun.
Yeah,
but they have 20 percent less as in that
vancouver.
A calculated metrics of comedy mix.
Yeah.
Great spot.
Awesome spot.
And you go right to your hotel.
You go,
it's in the hotel.
If you go down,
down to the bottom floor,
walk right into the club.
All clubs,
underground comedy works,
dcm,
prive.
If you live at a bad old copies that we
talked about.
All these great places.
Yep.
I'll just underground comedy club,
but there's something about it.
It's just fun.
Anyway,
so,
um,
I think there's three guys in the front
row and I look at them and they keep
going on in the bathroom,
like you just do coca and we
look at the bounce around.
I like these guys are clearly doing
coke.
No one you shot him in the front row and
then because.
Well they paid to sit in the front row.
That's a koch money.
Well,
vancouver is a big coke town.
Really?
Yeah.
It's a big weed town,
but it's aLso a big coke town.
They,
um,
I was one of the points where I had
sunday night after that said,
and I go after that weekend,
it's the last sentence.
I'm hanging out with this great comic up
there,
graeme clark and Bearded guy looks like
de young santa claus,
like all,
you know,
vancouver coMics and we go and we're
having drinks at a bar and you're buying
and these two girls send over these two
shots of Jack Daniels and um,
he's not attractive fella.
I'm no brenton job and so we go run yet
really?
Or they look over our shoulders.
This for us.
Okay.
It must've been at the show.
That's it must've been to jump.
They weren't at the show.
We're,
there's a lot of chicks in that town.
Maybe they wanted you to liver.
Yeah,
that's what I was thinking,
that I immediately go to fucking me in
the bathtub.
no,
oregon's wake up on you.
Totally.
I'm very suspicious because rocking her
wedding ring.
exactly.
Not people's sexiest man alive,
you know.
So I can,
my wife is very attractive,
but
I'm not pulling any chicks after shows.
And um,
the,
um,
no,
uh,
you know,
Brian Collins,
outgoing,
nice guy,
I'm not brian.
So why is this,
why they I know.
So then they come over and this is,
I've never felt so bad about these two
chicks are hot and I immediately go to,
we're going to die,
like they're trying to drag us and take
some shit.
And Then,
uh,
because I can't under offer any
explanation for it and now they're
congram and so we send them back shots
and we don't go over there.
We just like,
okay,
it's even now.
And then they come join us at a taBle
and then the one girl starts talking to
us.
We were like,
were you guys the show?
And they're like,
what?
Show?
And then I go onto we're chitchatting
and the one girl goes,
she goes,
I really want to go to strip clubs right
now.
And I said,
fuck,
in this second trucking fantasy for me,
it's,
if I can go to strip clubs with these
hot chicks and uh,
and graham looks at me and I go,
well,
I could a flight to catch.
And I guess I'll just see you guys
later.
Fucking walked awaY and that's never had
this happened in vancouver.
You walk around that cIty and I was just
placed called the cactus club.
And have you been there?
No.
Oh my god.
What is it?
They cast with head shots.
They uh,
they staff their whole place with head
shots.
Real.
It's the most gorgeous women you've ever
seen in your entire life.
working at a place.
Cactus club.
That cactus the cactus club.
I don't know where they came back.
So the uh,
they uh,
it's a lot of just hot chicks and that's
when I saw in vancouver was just
drinking hot chicks.
I think prostitution is legal road.
Do you think there are prostitutes?
They might've been prostitutes.
They got your drinks thinking they'll
get these guys intoxicated.
Look at him.
He's got glasses on executive or
something,
some more money.
He's got a little whore stash.
Beacon ors.
I just went to the beverly wilshire
hotel.
Where's that?
I did a private gig.
It's on right at the end of rodeo drive
in Beverly hills.
And then it's on wilshire and hits and
it's an old hotel and Me and tom papa
did a charity gig on monday night,
so then me and tom hit the bar
afterwards and proceed to watch parade
of high end or go through that place
picking off old men left and right to
the point where we're like,
we were just shocked that he was really
amazing.
Good looking ladies.
Well there's that.
There's that crazy beverly hills money.
You know,
just the other day I was looking at real
estate in beverly hills for a goof.
You ever looked at like the redfin app
though?
I love that.
I love to do that.
every now and then.
If I was going to move to beverly hills,
let's see what I can afford.
I'm looking at
like $17,000,000 house to $85 million.
A hundred million to $100 million.
Duke,
who's.
That's exactly who's buying it.
Well,
I went to dinner with my wife and one of
her friends,
her friend's husband,
and we went in beverly hills and this
guy pulled up in a million dollar car.
He had a bugatti Iran.
It's a million dollar car and it has
saudi arabian license plates on plated,
which is totally illegal.
It's totally illegal to have Saudi
Arabia license plates,
like they're taking these cars.
They either fly him over or they put
them on a boat.
They have them registered and Saudi
Arabia,
they bring them to America and they
drive around with these plates on it.
That palace plates,
like it said like palace on the fucking
plate and those guys warren taken
carries because there's so much money.
Yeah.
You remember that one guy that was like
some sort of a foreign dignitary guy and
he was banging his maids or force them
to suck his dick or something like that.
And they called the cops on him and they
aRrested him and then you know,
they were going to process them and
charge him with rape and he just fucking
hopped in a private jet and flew out of
the country and they were saying,
why did you let this guy go?
Oh,
fuck You.
Fuck you.
Diplomatic community.
He was crying.
Diplomatic immunity.
Yeah.
But I'm juSt thinking about my mate is
this old fucking mexican lady for
sinners.
The money it was arnold,
but he did get the money in that area
and beverly hills area is just,
it's catastrophic.
I mean it's stratospheric rather it's
off the charts.
like you can't even understand.
like the guy who makes good money is
poor there.
Your I'm a poor person there.
Yeah,
I do well,
but I'm poor.
There sure is.
When you get into oil money,
people who own money and even in the
United States,
we do have people that have been here
for so long and generate,
you know trump's ma mayflower fucking
shit where it's like,
oh yeah,
we own.
We used to have my family used to own
pasadena.
That's another tricky thing is say we've
talked about that is where there was so
much money in pasedena that they put
that to 10 freeway there.
That's white is where it is.
So they keep the black people on the
other side.
What's.
That's exactly what every ways there
where they keep the black people on
which side?
On the other side.
Now north of pasadena,
that to 10 separates out to dina.
That's where the black people are.
That's where the black people,
that's why they call it crime medina.
Really?
They called altadena crime medina.
No way.
Yeah,
that's rough up there.
Yeah.
We were playing weird playing this youth
basketball league when my son was maybe
like a fifth grader and that got the
nicest man in the world who ran a
basketball league.
Just got hit by a bullet in the head and
fucking dead.
Yeah,
pasadena streets.
There was this park.
He got shot in pasedena.
Just stray bullet.
A stray bullet.
Yeah.
Who they shooting at each other?
You know,
gangs.
Whoa.
In pasadena,
there's gang violence in pasadena.
Shit load of it.
What are the ice house?
Not near the ice house.
Ice houses on the right side.
A south side.
This is the freeway.
Go fucking north of that freeway and go
up into the hills right there and
there's a shitload of crime.
Shitload.
Wow.
I saw there's this place called villa
park where my son was playing soccer and
we went there and I saw guys getting
their haircut in the street,
like a stock guy sit down and just
buzzing and lines of people just giving
haircuts in the street and everybody
watch out like this fucking rough
neighborhood.
We're just dudes getting haircuts in the
street and you're like,
fucking everybody look alive.
It's rough.
It's a lot of latinos,
you know.
And there's also a lot of um,
black on mexican crime member when that
was happening in the nla,
the mexican guys were just shooting
black people,
not black people really read any of
them.
Yep.
Why trying to run them out of
neighborhoods.
Whoa.
Yep.
When you get into like ms 13 shit.
Yeah.
Convinced it starts to get.
Well,
that's where like Gary White people get
really pro trump,
you know,
they're,
they get very excited about trump and
that's ms.
[inaudible] is one of the things that
they keep bringing it up and all these
illegal immigrants that have these gangs
for the most part.
When you look at all of the people
coming in to work,
they don't want any trouble shore.
Nobody.
Everybody wants to keep their head down
work these so I can give themselves a
chance.
Road,
trouble it with anything.
There's going to be bad apples.
There's going to be the guy in san
francisco that everybody keeps referring
to kind of be gangs,
but you know what?
I see that everYwhere I go,
that is a huge fucking problem that is
going to just spreading like wildfire is
fucking math.
Yeah.
Math.
Oh,
thInk when you go an adderall,
by the way.
Adderalls ben.
Oh,
it's a huge problem and it leads people
to meth.
Really?
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Adderall and meth are closely related.
Very closely related.
If they're both amphetamines.
I took a half adderall once and I was
like,
oh,
I'm never doing that again.
Fuck yeah,
I do.
I'm not too good on drugs.
It's a.
I took.
Freddy soto gave me an ambien who was an
ambien,
unfortunately to the men,
wasn't it?
It had to be sleep apnea.
That yeah,
he's fat and sIck,
you know,
drugs
and sleep apnea.
Parents,
a lethal combination because you don't
feel yourself choking.
Yeah,
he gave me an ambien.
I,
we moved.
I took it as like I needed to take a nap
and that was all wound up.
I slept for five hours straight in the
middle of the day and I was like,
I'm never fucking taken that again.
And then,
um,
took this adderall and just felt all
fucked up and just never.
I'm like,
I don't think my body don't know,
just,
uh,
I don't do anything.
I was getting really tired during the
day and I remember you told me to take
some vitamin d and so we started taking
a multivitamin and that really helps me
and I take a lot of b 12.
That helps.
And it would also help you in a big way,
cut out all the bread and sugar and
carbs and all that stuff because then
the insulin spikes,
you're not getting these big spikes,
which is a big reason why people crash
the other day.
It's bread,
bread,
pasta,
all that stuff.
Like your body goes too far and your
body has to process that and you get
this big slump is soon as you cut all
that out.
You experience a much,
even much more even flow of energy
through the day.
Yeah.
So if I could just learn to um,
do like that.
Like I'm like,
I'm again,
I'm such a glutton man.
A bread when the kids were,
my wife has making,
gives you a fresh loaves of this artist
and bread that she has.
Then steve may bring peanut butter and
jelly and it seems like I just like a
scavenger.
I'm a family goat.
Like I'll just cross
out all the kids leave behind.
Sometimes it's stuff dealing with
ordering food for myself at a restaurant
because I know that everyone's going to
leave half their shit or all order
myself a full entree and then somebody
will have half a chicken parmigiana or
something over on it because my son and
daughter and system ordering off the
kid's menu.
And so now I got somebody eating a full
chicken parmesan,
but they'll only eat half of it and I'm
not going to let that go to waste.
And so I'll start digging into that and
then there's pasta.
They're like,
let me just try one of those raviolis
and then all of a sudden I eat like
fucking three dinners.
So I weigh more than i ever have weighed
in my entire life right now.
Wow.
One 93,
five,
10.
Yeah.
Wow.
I think again,
I go to the gym on a regular basis and I
left and said like that.
But yeah,
I fucking 193 pounds.
Yeah,
it's the pasta and bread man.
If you just cut all that stuff out,
you'll drop a shitload of weight right
away.
I could be in the family goat.
That'll help.
That was one of the things when we were
talking about that I think is kind of
reporting like when you're talking about
um,
immigration and bad apples and stuff
like that.
I look at immigration that same way.
I look at gun control,
like most people that have guns are laW
abiding citizens.
And it's not going to be a problem.
The vast,
vast majority.
And I think that's the same case with
immigration and the same case with
people coming to America,
even illegally,
they want to do Better.
That's why they're coming here.
They're not coming here because they
want to start crying and they,
most of them are coming here because
they want opportunities with guns.
I totally agree.
I want a shotgun so badly when I needed
a double barrel.
Like I want a shotgun and uM,
I've shot a lot of guns should,
especially with the daily show.
I've done chuck jones for the daily
shot.
Got tori.
Yeah.
I was going to be telling jokes,
going to have to learn how to fucking
clear room and defend yourself.
Okay.
All right.
Now this is a thompson machine gun
discipline.
Very important for the dailies.
Cheryl,
a 50 caliber sniper busters.
50 calibers are ridiculous.
Dude,
I will show you a video after this.
Actually,
maybe this hasn't really even aired
because it was part of a pilot that I
did that did.
I did a pilot for comedy central when I
left the daily show.
It was an anti travel show called
displaced.
Sucks.
Didn't go through.
I'll send it to you.
Great idea.
Just the con
dude.
It's the fucking funny.
You know what they said?
Well,
I mean,
everybody said it was too mean.
It's fucking hilarious.
I go,
we stayed in Kansas city.
hey everybody.
My name's al madrigal.
I'm in Kansas city.
I'm going to tell you why this place
sucks.
Just shit all over it and it to just do
that online.
Oh yeah.
I should just put them out.
Soy diet is a great idea for all things
comedy.
why don't you just like buy our main
idea?
I totally just,
you own the idea,
my idea.
Oh my god,
that's a great idea.
so the idea,
like as soon as you set it up,
you know,
someone says an idea in a light bulb
goes off a real idea,
and I do it in san francisco when I do
it at san francisco is fucking filthy.
It is one of the dirtiest cities I've
ever been in my entire life.
And also it's like filled with rich
douche bags now because of the internet.
Boom.
And then all this tech boom and the poor
people are getting moved out.
There's so much stuff to make fun of.
So anyway,
I'm paid fun of aI.
went to this place,
omb,
guns and I shot machine guns,
handguns,
like a shot,
everything.
And then for the daily show I went and I
drove a tank.
I got to drive tanks.
I was doing this chieftain tanks that I
was driving.
I got to run over to saturn's in a tank.
Really fucking awesome.
How do you drive a tank?
Like What do you,
what do you,
you know?
Yeah,
it's levers and there's a.
So um,
yeah,
you could watch and there was this hot
chick that they had that was working
there that was on it with me and at the
same place I got to fire machine guns.
But I feel like when it comes to
automatic weapons and a 50 caliber
sniper buster and all that shit,
I don't understand why you need to own
that.
I liked shooting it.
I'll go shoot that stuff again.
I really enjoyed it.
And you can see me shoot that 50 caliber
thing,
like there was a shockwave,
like your,
your head flies,
but you couldn't watch my arms and the
skin on my arms ripple after I fucking.
Because I wore a sleeveless shirt.
Shoot It.
Boom.
Wow.
And uh,
I enjoyed it.
I liked shooting that shit.
I want the shotgun to defend my house
when everything goes to hell.
I'll be approximate zombie apocalypse
and nice shotgun.
I want just somebody to here get the
fuck away from the door.
You know,
I have by my bed right now.
Hammers,
hammer.
I have a hammer like bill makes it
thinks it's the craziest thing.
Like you keep it by your bed.
I keep a hammer under my bed.
Like I'm going to fucking get up and
close contact.
Like hammering somebody with death.
Yeah.
It seems like you've thought it through,
like really,
really like on a surface level.
I have a magnum flashlight and high flat
magnum flashlight.
Yeah.
Peter,
that always kIlls me.
That people think they're going to club
somebody with flashlight.
No,
no.
I want to.
I'm a flashlight in one hand.
So lined him and then fucking run in and
my hammer.
why not a real weapon?
I want a real one.
I got knives.
I have all closed.
Contacted me.
Never got a gun on my wife second.
Oh,
one of them.
Yup.
I'll get one.
I'm working on her.
She's good.
She gets it.
Yeah.
We've got to do as a false flag in the
house.
Hire some friends of brick in.
Oh yeah,
that's a good idea.
Not false flag.
The dick cheney of households.
Oh zero.
Um,
yeah.
I want the gun badly.
But I feel like with an ak 47 and maybe
people can write like only bad things
have happened with people.
You know a district is responsible gun
owners.
But you look at dylan roof and you look
at columbine,
you look at all these people getting
shot up everywhere and seeing the hook.
Like I don't want that to happen.
I don't want my kids.
I was walking away.
I was safe.
You put your guns in a safe.
Why do you need an ak 47?
Don't you don't need an ak 47.
I'm saying to have all the handgun,
but the thing is like,
who should be able to decide who gets
what.
That's where it gets weird.
yeah.
And what about silencers to.
Well,
here's the thing in,
in europe,
silencers are thought of as a polite
thing because we're over in America
worried about shooting people.
They're worrying about noise.
So like if you have a,
what they call suppressor,
that suppressor,
like if you're hunting,
you would hunt with a suppressor on
because you don't want to blow your
fucking ears.
Man.
I'll put the links out to these two
pieces that I did a daily show spots.
I'll do the one.
If you go to my thing that twitter,
uh,
I'll,
I'll put it on.
I'll send them to you.
That when I drove a tank and fired all
those guns.
And then I did a silencer piece as well.
And the guy was saying he wanted to
protect kids ears with the silencers.
And that's what Donald Trump is saying.
Kids.
And I'm worried.
the reality is though,
and this is true,
I know a lot of friends that are hunters
that shot guns as kids and they're
fucked up now.
They're ears are a mess.
They the.
They should,
but they didn't when they were younger
because they didn't know any better.
See,
20 years ago people didn't know that you
were going to do permanent damage to
your ears.
They didn't.
You didn't need.
Never heard about it.
Like these people just shotguns,
but I think also the uNfortunate reality
now is that you Could have somebody
walking around undetected shooting,
shooting people in a college and you
could call it why I did,
I was on kcrw and walking around the
Santa monica campus and I really did
think I'm like,
okay,
who's the shooter Coast water?
And then it shouldn't be a thought that.
No,
it shouldn't.
Yeah.
I mean it's a mental health issue when
he was like the only person that's
capable of doing that as a person who's
sick.
Yeah.
You know,
and that's the other thing that doesn't
come up when you're talking about mass
shootings is whenever you hear about it,
the news,
nobody makes the correlation,
the inescapable correlation between
psychoactive drugs and mass shootings
because there's a lot of fucking mass
shooters,
like almost all of them that are either
on pharmaceutical drugs like ssri
disassociative drugs or they're getting
off of um,
anti psychotic drugs.
There's what can be done is you're like,
there is no common ground.
We started having people make.
We live in this country where you should
be able to do whatever you want and hAve
whatever you want.
But then who gets to decide who gets
crushed in what guns?
Well,
Texas has sort of taken the idea that
just everyBody has a gun,
a well armed society is a polite
society.
Well,
my ron white all of a sudden,
and then teachers should have guns in
the classroom.
And bulletproof helmets,
full vests.
Jesus,
ak,
47 is right there,
right there.
Put down the truck.
I don't know man.
It sucks yet.
Think about it.
There's no easy solution.
Yeah,
well it just,
every time.
one of those things happens,
everybody buckles down and wants to take
away guns and try to figure out
legislation and I just feel like the
root of the problem is not the tools
that people are using.
It's the fact that someone's willing to
use those tools,
the fact that someone is willing to do
that,
the fact that those guns are more
accessible is a genuine issue.
But I think we can all agree that no one
came for the guns.
Uh,
obama,
every single obama's coming for the guns
will.
Do you know why he knows deanna,
right?
Because the nra is too strong.
The lobbies too strong,
they,
they've spent a shitload of money and
continue to spend a shitload of money to
make sure they protect the second
amendment rights.
So you're saying if they will,
if not for the nra,
dash a hundred percent have taken all
the guns,
they would have definitely done
something similar to what Australia did.
Australia essentially made gun ownership
very,
very difficult.
They took away guns.
They,
they enact a very strict laws and they
had like one mass shooting at a long
time ago.
Had a big mass shooting a long time ago.
That's the thing.
That's the only habit is like these big
mass shootings,
you know,
when you see.
But Australia has the same amount of
people's California and it's the size of
the United States.
Yeah.
They just,
I just saw the thing.
There was a map comparisons until your
mind is like,
it's the exact same says yeah,
it's crazy and people are spread way
spread out and it's the same amount of
people's los angeles and it's in this
giant ass fucking country.
So when you think about being able to
take people's guns in Australia,
it's different.
The culture is different.
The,
the idea of independence is different
over there.
we have a different attitude over here.
yeah.
I just don't want to.
um,
yeah.
When you have little kids again.
Yeah.
Your changes,
you know,
or just like,
I don't want ever.
Why worry about them growing up in a
society where a teacher does have to
think about wearing a fucking helmet.
Of course,
of course.
I mean nobody wants to think that.
I don't know what the solution is,
but the solution.
Look,
getting the guns away from the people.
There's more guns than there are human
beings in America and they're not.
They're not going to stop making guns.
No good business guns of the problem.
I really don't.
I mean,
I support gun ownership.
I really do.
I don't think that's the issue.
I think the issue is that we saw in
France and nice that some crazy fucking
take a car and kill 100 people by
plowing over pizza and just started
stabbing people to get out of the car
and just fucking start stabbing folks.
There's,
there's ways that people lose their
fucking minds and do horrible things to
people and the ways are not things you
have to take away.
You have to figure out a way and not
take away all hammers.
No,
I don't know what the solution is,
but I don't think anybody does.
But I think what you're getting at with
the mental health stuff is there.
I'm not opposed to there being a
screening process and seeing if you have
a history of violence.
Of course.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
if you are show up on a terrorist watch
list and that's where I think the nra
goes overboard,
like if you're on a fucking terrorist
watch list,
who doesn't agree with that?
Well,
the only problem with thAt is who gets
to decide who's on the terrorist watch
list because there was people that were
um,
from uh,
the green party that were put on
terrorist watch list after nine slash 11
because they were anti war protesters
and they were put on no fly list.
There was a lot of weird shit that
happened where people were put on lists
because they pissed off the wrong
people.
And you know,
in 2001 it was way easier to do
something like that,
but it is to go to buy a gun and then
they say,
I'm sure he can purchase his weapon
because you're on that list.
And then you go to a gun show that's
part of the problem.
You go to a gun show and you can buy a
gun far easier in Kansas city trying to
tighten that down though.
Kansas,
you can go and correct me If I'm wrong,
it didn't choke up.
This place sucks.
What am I still go to Kansas and then
you can get a gun with.
No,
you don't.
You can just an id Kansas id and get it
in maybe like five minutes.
Zero traIn.
It's nothing.
Just you get it right away.
You don't have to have a background
check.
Nothing.
So is that true?
Yes.
Was that like when you did in 2014?
I did this Piece yet.
But you can look at it.
Can we,
can we check the gun laws?
Kansas?
No background check.
I'm pretty certain.
So why wouldn't you have to disclose in
Kansas?
Listening to this guy he does with his
grandma,
he walks into this place and he goes,
uh,
I can't.
The guy says I caN't buy the gun,
but she can like that he buys these four
guns or something.
Kills a bunch of people.
So federal law requires federallY
licensed firearms dealers but not
private sellers to initiate a background
check on the purchase purchaser prior to
sale a firearm.
As a result,
concealed weapons license holders in
Kansas are exempt from the federal
background check requirement.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
No training,
no background check hold on.
A second.
Concealed weapons license holders like
you have to have a concealed weapons
license,
which is difficult to acquire and it's
not easy to get a concealed weapons
license unless they have a different
law,
theIr background checks and cans,
concealed weapon,
but I think concealed weapons is like
the hardest thing to get is a concealed
carry.
Federal law provides states with the
options of serving as state.
Kansas has no law requiring firearms
dealers to initiate background checks
prior to transferring a firearm.
As a result in Kansas,
firearms dealers must initiate the
backgrouNd check required by federal
law,
bY contacting the fbi directly.
Kansas is not a point of contact state,
huh?
So they have to contact the fbi.
A federal law does not require dealers
to conduct a background check of a
firearm.
Purchaser presents a state permit to
purchase or possess firearms.
It meets certain conditions.
So it seems like tHere's definitely some
wiggle room.
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
And then you know,
that's an area is talking about these
gun shows where you can just go gobble
up a bunch of firearms and that he can
bring them into.
That's what they just transport them
across state lines and it's one of those
things like many human issues where
there's not a whole lot of like clear
paths.
It's like there's so many guns.
You're never going to take them all away
from people.
And should you take them all away from
him?
Like if a guy like you as a gun,
I don't feel like danger a threat unless
you get in one of your god damn tirade.
He might maybe have another best example
that hack
fucking stealing.
So
did you hear that?
Bit like a.
Not a bid.
The video.
Carlos min sia was on joey diaz a show
saying that he thought about bringing a
gun around,
going to the comedy store and shooting
people and he was carrying a gun in his
car.
Like,
no way,
I'm crazy while there maybe you
shouldn't have a gun.
That'S where I started thinking about
Ohio,
which brings me back and then started
thinking about,
you know,
I look at redfin,
trulia.
I would go to,
oh,
I'm living out there and you live in
Ohio was weird.
Checking out.
I was in Ohio recently.
It's weird.
Really?
Yeah.
Everybody talks about how great it is.
I think the resort is great.
Oh yeah.
We did an airbnb out there in Ohio
was like,
eh,
that's true.
Not feeling would have been nice
restaurants.
What about when you get out to like
cdot?
Oh,
that's fucking beautiful.
That's like one percent or that's like
$12,000,000 house territory.
That's really a saudi arabian.
Sheik has a beautiful rich people found
a good spot.
Yeah,
they really did have.
I liked that.
Santa barbara.
I liked it.
See any as I like to go up the coast to
verbally looks this.
You want to go look at deck kane?
Bria,
where's that?
That's in the middle of California.
It's Just a coastal town.
There's a place called avalon beach.
It's all.
It gets into like san louis obispo
county,
a random middle of people haven't.
It's a little bit too far to drive.
It'll take like three and a half hours
at la.
Little town.
Walked to the coffee place with the
dogs.
My buddy john hackleman lives in san
luis obispo,
who's a chocolate.
So I'm a karate training.
I would say accounts probably with a
chocolate down.
Did you really didn't know him or
anything?
I just knew that fuckIng guy.
What is this?
Tambria is pretty.
Yeah,
just the one.
Oh,
yep.
Yeah,
that's pretty.
It looks quiet.
But uh,
san luis obispo for fucking great.
There's no one there.
It's just the college and it's real
quiet.
morro bay is also another big rock and
then you can just go fish.
You can do a bunch of shit like that.
So that's again,
I'm,
I am so high strung and I do feel like
I'm prone to like I can't be walking
around telling dads at my school to fuck
off and do that.
I told one guy to go find go,
you're a fucking asshole.
You know what happened?
You're just re.
He's a fucking dick to my son.
The dad was,
dad was,
he was a basketball coach and I saw him.
I go,
hey,
real asshole,
you know that.
Well,
and uh,
because no dad's talked to each other
like that,
and I call this guy an asshole and I
felt bad.
I can feel fucking band.
I don't want to do it,
but I did it.
And he's a dick and everybody knows he's
a fucking dick in your coach.
Hey,
coach at a school.
Yeah.
Is it still there or is it done and he's
done.
He's done.
Yeah.
well,
it's a lot of people that can't let the
stress of being a comic.
Right.
It's one kras trust.
Imagine the stress of dealing with
hormonally active seventeen-year-old
every fucking year.
New ones coming in.
Just chaos younger team now.
Not even that.
Just being an asshole to an 11 year old.
Oh,
well,
he's a piece of shit.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Well there's a lot of fucking stress and
raIsing people and teaching kids and
dealing with the problems that kids
present.
You know,
a lot of people that just.
Here's another thing that's going on
today.
People think that they can have a kid
and then have careers too,
and everyone's having a career at the
mom has a career that data as a career,
but he has a career and when you're
watching the kid who's paying attention
to the kid.
I went to a party and I've talked
about this in the podcast before.
This one little kid was just running
around hitting everybody and do it.
The parents are inside drinking there in
the party drinking and the kids out
there with the other kids and then
finally the guy comes down to apologize.
I'm sorry.
He's a good kid.
He's not a good kid.
like he's hit three kids.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I told them when he,
what the kid did,
he goes,
he never did that.
I go,
I saw him do that.
Watch your son being and the guys,
like I said,
I'm sorry.
I'm like,
oh my god,
I want to kill you.
Do you understand?
I want to grab your neck and choke the
life out of you.
I'm containing mySelf.
You fucking cunt.
Yes.
So I get into putting those seeds.
Yeah,
but I keep it cool.
I keep it called magic.
How do you do it?
I don't know if i.
Because I practice murder on a daily
basis.
oh my god.
I just murdered a punching bag or run up
hills.
I get it out of my system.
Birch just told me this story about you
exercising sets come a un tate and that
guy with his shirt off that was trying
to get into your hotel room.
Oh yeah.
And I would've fucking.
I don't know what I would've done if I'm
not going to,
you know,
that's the other thIng.
It's like I would just put it,
that guy wound up being unconscious
tape,
put them to sleep to choke them
unconscious.
But it was nice to him.
He could have taken his life.
That guy was a real piece of shit.
He was a big giant dude.
He was like six foot six and he was a
bully and he thought because he was so
tall,
he thought that people were scared of
him,
but you know he fucked with the wrong
guy in tate.
First of all,
a guy who's been arrested,
been around bad people his whole life,
been in numerous treat.
fights was a professIonal fighter,
was on the ultimate fighter,
was a black belt In jujitsu,
mean everything was wrong and tate was
trying to be calm with the guy and the
way tate handled it like he it.
They fought in a hotel lobby right in
front of the elevator and the guy was
pounded on his door saying,
you're in my fucking room.
I think I was just a cunt.
And a tape was like,
no,
look,
my key works here.
It's definitely my room.
And he shuts the door and he was,
hey,
fucking faggot.
you think you can get away with shutting
this fucking door?
Who was open this fucking door?
Told you in my room and then we all went
outside.
It was me and eddie,
bravo and tate.
We're looking at this guy and we're
lookIng at his friend and we're trying
to figure out how we're going to do this
like this.
This has to be dealt with.
Like,
this is not a guy that's going to go
away.
He was a big drunk dumb guy and tate
decides the way to handle it is,
um,
you know,
there's a bunch of words being
exchanged.
So tate decides he,
uh,
he kicks the guy in a legs in the leg
and then he grabs them and pulls him on
top of him.
So the guy like literally has no idea,
like why?
So he kicks his leg,
grabs them and pulls them on top of them
and pulls them into what's called the
guard,
you know,
like in jujitsu and then wraps them up
and something called an omoplata,
which is a shoulder lock.
So he throws,
I mean,
this is all instantaneous kick pole
throws his shoulder over them.
Then the security guard show up,
the security guard show up and they go,
hey,
what the fuck is going on?
And I go,
relax.
I go,
everything's gonna.
Be fine.
He's just going to choke him to sleep
and they got the security guard goes.
Joe rogan,
joe rogan.
Holy shit,
man.
What are you doing here while I said
this,
like he's just gonna choke him asleep.
Take goes.
All right.
I guess I'm going to choke them asleep
now.
I mean this is all happening.
Within seconds.
Tate sinks in a rear naked choke on this
guy and just squeezes them unconscious,
gets off of them.
Doesn't hurt the guy at all.
It doesn't hit him all.
He does kick his leg out from under him.
Take them down,
choke them unconscious.
The guy,
his friend picks his friend up.
I and I go get your fucking friend and
get sober him up and get him out of
here.
And he's lucky.
Nothing happened and he's like,
sorry man,
my friends,
piece of shit.
I'm sorry.
his friend picks his friend up.
the guys like delirious.
They push them in an elevator elevator
door closes.
He disappears from life.
Never seen him again.
That's it.
The end of it.
I'd take pictures with the fucking
security guards there smiling like it
was fine.
It goes a drunk asshole.
Just think we should call the cops.
I go,
no,
that guy's humiliated.
Like unless he comes back,
he comes back,
he's going to get fucked up,
but right now everything's fine.
Don't call the cops.
So they laughing and everyone's
laughing.
We took a couple pictures together,
went back in the room,
went and got some dinner and we were
laughing.
Yeah.
But when that dad is in your face at the
party,
that exercise that come,
uh,
is,
that's again,
that's the thing that I struggled with
when mike costa is onstage and I'm being
completely honest.
Like again,
this is how I feel and it's just
somebody that takes over and I'm like,
I can't help but say,
hey,
your son is hitting that guy.
Like,
this is not cool.
This is not okay.
Parents don't want their kids and their
kids are just compLete asshole.
Well,
they go to parties and they drink and
they leave the kIds outside and this
parents,
these particular parents,
they don't watch the kid ever.
They.
This is like what they're famous for
apparently in their group that just
don't watch this kid.
They just,
they don't want to be parents.
They became parents in their forties.
They didn't
really planned it out that I don't know
if the parents get along.
I dunno.
I dunno how we put the whole thing looks
like a disaster and the kids a little
monster and they just are not.
They're not disciplining him,
paying attention and like he literally
went out and talked to the kid and there
was some commotion going on.
Were people complaining about the kid
hitting somebody?
He talked to the kid and then he high
fived him and then the kid went back to
doing it again.
I mean literally he went back inside to
drink.
The kid went back outside again.
So at the end of the night when this guy
apologized to me like it,
if the kid was doing it all,
now I go,
hey man,
your kid is really aggressive.
And he's like,
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry about the kid I go,
your kid is really aggressive with no,
he's a good kid.
I go,
don't look.
He hit,
he hit three people.
I saw him hit people,
I saw them push a kid and call him a
loser.
I go,
he's fucking six and he's doing this.
He goes,
that never happened.
You know,
I had to understand consequences.
This is why I bite my tongue.
I understand like the,
the actual consequences of,
of smacking this guy and his fucking
mouth,
which is what I wanted to do,
you know?
Of course,
if there was no consequences to doing
anything and I didn't think of him as a
person.
I didn't think of him as a guy who just
never raised the kid before,
hasn't really thought about it.
Well,
has a big career,
probably busy all the time.
Wife's busy all the time.
Just not doing a good job raising a
little monster,
you know,
drinking to try to drown out the facts.
Who knows why,
you know,
drinking because he doesn't like being
married,
drinking because he doesn't like being a
dad.
Drinking because he doesn't like being
sober.
Who knows?
I don't know.
I don't know the guy,
but in that moment when he's looking at
me and going,
that never happened.
I just did just to the fucking sheer
ignorance and incompetence and
irresponsibility was just so infuriating
because I've watched my kids,
like I've watched them,
I talk to them,
I communicate with them.
I know I didn't have a good childhood,
so for me it's important to be a good
dad and spend as much time as I can.
Communicate,
explaining shit,
talk to them,
treating them like I'm not just their
dad,
but also I'm their friend and I care
about them.
My wife is a first grade teacher and
she's become a educational therapists
right now,
so I'm like living with just the master
at consequences.
Like if you don't eat in our house or
decide you don't like broccoli,
nothing else is coming.
Good kitchen is closed and that's when
people create monsters.
When they cater to them so much.
That's okay.
Let me in and that's where you like your
kid only eats fucking rice.
I have a friend who and he keeps feeding
this fucking kid sugar.
This kid just eats nothing but sugar all
day because he doesn't need.
He doesn't eat.
I go,
what do you mean he doesn't eat?
He's always eating cookies because he
won't eat his food.
I got to feed him something.
I go,
no,
dude,
you got to tell them you can't eat the
cookies.
You've got food.
You've got actual food.
This fucking kid is just eating nothing
but candy.
I mean it's.
It's bananas.
He's always got a soda in his hand.
Oh
good.
He's six.
He's fucking six and he's drinking a
full coke or you go over the house.
The kid has a root beer.
We sell these kids.
We were on a flight and a saudis to
parents sit in first class and then come
back and check.
We didn't know what was going on and
coach.
They put three next to each other and
coach some motherfuckers I know.
Crazy.
Right?
And then everybody else has to do with
their kid.
They gave each of them my pants.
Right.
And then they waitress,
the waitress or the stewardess comes by
and she looks at these three kids and
looks around for who they're with and
the one that will have the kids.
I'm telling eight is the oldest one,
a maybe six and four.
Three just in a row.
Jesus christ,
the oldest one goes three sprites,
sprites.
This is a red eye,
is an overnight flight.
They're on ipads,
like just animals just
don't stop trying to win something.
And then,
um,
my wife were sort of laughing at first,
but everybody in our family wants to go
to sleep.
They already exhausted from being out
all day.
I've never is a while ago.
I'll never be on this flight again.
No red eyes for me.
This horrible,
horrible,
ruined for days,
two days afterwards.
You're fucked.
Yeah.
Tried to do anything in your power to
avoid a read.
I also try to do everything in your
power to avoid.
I'm looking at if you can fly nonstop,
that's 100 percent.
Yep.
So they get in a fight after a while,
start fighting because they're all
hopped up on sugar and they were staring
at the screen and fucking so then they
started fighting and I think the mom or
the dad hears or somebody has to tap
them to get up and me and my wife was
like,
this is not okay.
Nothing was said because again,
we just want to monitor on business.
Ideally,
again,
ideally everyone minds their own
business.
This is a new world though.
This world of electronic babysitters and
the world of putting the kids and coach
and you go into first class,
like ignoring kids and it's these career
people.
There's a lot of people that look,
they their career requires all their
time.
They justified by go look,
someone's gotta make the money in this
household so we can keep up this
lifestyle.
And so they're out there fucking
grinding all day and then the kids are
just,
what do I do?
It be me full circle to my dad passing
away.
He's at every single weekend and this is
why I bought that fj 62 lane cruiser
because every single weekend we went on
a little family trip and I looked at
myself and we'd go on family vacations
and stuff,
but the amount of time that my family
really spent together like a mom and a
dad,
like he would take us to yosemite.
He would take us up the coast of
mendocino,
we'd go to marin or stinson beach and
all these places,
even in golden gate park.
Like he would just take us places,
little adventures,
you know.
And so I feel like we need to,
I get caught up in work working because
it just nonstop and I got to take a step
back and really spend as much time as I
possibly can.
So after that happened,
and this is june,
so almost a year ago,
just really tried trim back.
I go to every single volleyball game.
I go to every practice I possibly can,
you know,
and just force yourself to say this is
not,
it doesn't matter that much because you
look at all these deathbed.
That's what I started looking at all
these deathbed regrets.
Those are a bunch of lists that are out
there.
Jesus,
too much time spent at work.
yeah.
not enough time spent with people that I
love,
you know,
and look at all these things and it's
like,
fuck it,
I'm not having any of these regrets.
So that's What I'm thinking.
I started looking at the real estate and
trying to look at getting away,
you know,
just really check it out.
And that's what I'm trying to hustle and
make as much money as I and kids who are
in a house.
Where are you going to go?
That's what I'm checking into.
That's what I know a lot about
cambridge.
That's a big sur or one of those places
I could go up there and you're,
you're away and just live on the coast
and then be able to come back.
Like if I get an acting gig,
I love acting.
I like,
I really enjoy it.
I love writing too.
I was luckily had some success recently
as a comedy writer and um,
it's one of the cbs people I was trying
to match up with the latino show runner
and two years ago they go,
no,
that's,
that's you,
you're going to be that guy.
There aren't really any,
but we're grooming you to be that.
And I wrote too big scripts and then
that business background,
I have the ability to do that.
I like,
I like working with people and I think I
could staff up and do all that shit so I
could see myself splitting my time,
keeping my little house in la and then
having a place in cambria or santa
barbara and just fucking go back and
forth.
Santa barbara is easy.
It's only an hour,
hour and 10 just living on the beach and
have a blue heeler be able to sit back
and watch the ocean.
Just calm yourself,
calm yourself,
you know.
And that's what,
again,
fucking ari shaffir said that when he
was walking on a beach and he needed to
walk to a restaurant,
40 minutes,
that he had this feeling in his head
that oh,
I need to be doing something right now
and that he needed to curb that and he
needed to just watch the waves.
Yeah.
That was it.
Not think about.
And that's what I have is the problem I
have is I have a.
When you try to meditate,
people have said there's a river of
20,000 thoughts that you get just
nonstop.
And I've been waking up every single
night at 2:00 in the morning every
night,
almost.
Not every night,
but four or five nights a week.
Why
different reasons to think about
thoughts just and then just thinking
about stuff nonstop.
Well,
let's just see what you're saying to me.
Two different contradictory things.
You're saying that you want peace and
you want calm and then you're saying you
want to start running shows and then
you're saying you want to start having
multiple careers.
I want to be able to work on coming into
town.
Do a gig,
right?
You caN't be a show runner.
Work on a thing for like you sAid,
the show that I'm on is 10 episodes and
we worked on that for five months and
then I wanted to do nothing else.
Right.
But you know that when you work on a
show,
you're working 16 hour days.
Like if you want to be a show runner for
a successful show that the amount of
time that's required to actually make
something take off sure was massive.
We you have to manage a bunch of
different people and expectations and.
but it's a.
It's a portion of your year,
so it'd be like working seasonal work
almost secret.
You just.
That's It for me.
That's the ideal version.
Has to act on a show that has a episode
order and then go back to santa barbara
and then do nothing,
saw a bad idea and then come back and be
able to just control your own work is
really what I want to do.
You need to financial freedom to be able
to do that and then those shows pay
really well.
So I'm just trying to map out and I
don't have the answer.
I'm thinking,
and this is certainly not something I'm
doing right now,
but again,
when you work seasonally and then you
can really take some time to just hang
out and read on a deck and make dinner
and that's your go shop for an
individual meal every day.
Go and fish and do shit like that.
yeah.
You seem like you're longing for this.
I'm idealistic view of peace and quiet
while pursuing chaos.
Yeah,
they're very contradictory.
You understand what I'm saying?
Totally will.
ThiS is something that I promised myself
I was going to bust my ass until I was
50 and I'm 48.
I'm about to turn 46 and then just take
it as it comes when realistically as she
just take it as it comes right now and
not now.
I hustle really hard.
You know?
I have 10 things going on.
Yeah.
It's a weird balancing act trying to
figure out,
figure out how to manage your life for
ultimate happiness and then sometimes
like that the real ultimate happiness
comes after you've had struggle.
Like you only really appreciate sunlight
if you get a lot of rain,
like we don't have.
Like I went to prince of wales island in
Alaska for six days once and we were up
there camping.
It's fuckiNg miserable pouring rain
every day.
But when I came back to la,
God damn,
I was happy.
The sunlight felt so good.
I mean it felt like the sunlight's out
there right now.
It doesn't feel like shit.
I get mY car,
god,
it's hot.
I drive off.
I don't appreciate it,
but when I came back from Alaska I
really fucking appreciate it and I feel
like some amount of the peace and quiet
that we seek and we enjoy.
You're only gonna.
Appreciate it.
If you struggle like you're only going
to appreciate like real relaxation feet
up out the beach if you've been busting
your ass.
For me,
What I think a tremendous amount of calm
comes from is,
and this is,
I don't know,
you can tell me is just financial
freedom.
like I don't have a house payment
hanging over my head and I don't have
all this stuff that I'm just worried
about and I,
I tend to worry a lot about that stuff.
That's why I worked my ass off.
Like I really want to just.
And I'm over complicating my life,
but I am and,
and david really big.
You see me?
I'm Like,
I'm a happy guy,
but I just,
when we waken up in the middle of the
night at 2:00 in the morning thinking
about all the shit that you have to do,
you had to pare some stuff.
Yeah,
there's that for sure.
When you're a financially free,
it removes a gigantic burden.
I remember my first development deal.
That was the first thing I felt.
I got a development deal way back in the
nineties and the first thing that
happened,
they sent me thIs big fat check and all
of a sudden I felt lighter.
Like,
like something.
Like I took a backpack off,
filled with rocks.
Like ugh.
Now I knew that I could paY my bills for
the foreseeable future.
I was going to be able to pay my bills
for the next,
like more than a year if I wanted to do
nothing,
sit back for a year and live the way I'm
living,
I'd have no problem paying my bills.
And uh,
it was a very tangible feeling like,
okay,
now that I have this momentum,
I've got to keep this going because I
don't ever want to go back to that
feeling of not being able to pay my
bills because that's the real struggle.
The real struggle is like financial
independence.
Once You become financially independent,
then there's levels to it,
you know,
like you want to have one of those
monosito houses or have a fucking
private jet or you want to get crazier
and crazier and crazier.
You're just so overly confident.
That's like the assistant thing.
Exactly.
That's kind of.
So I feel like this level right here.
So I'm living in the house that I want
to live in.
I'm not,
I'm never moving and we're good to,
in terms of the la sort of raising my
kids house like a,
we're in a great little place.
I love it.
I live in pasadena second.
There's the wildlife in your yard.
You send me pictures of deer in your
yard.
Exactly.
There's deer,
coyotes,
bobcats jumped out behind me the other
day.
Jesus.
Yeah.
It was running as bears and in the past
dean happened to people's pools only in
the black neighborhooD.
So yes.
Black bears too weird.
It totally.
And so what they.
I'm,
I'm cool.
I don't want,
I don't need to fly private.
I don't need to.
I'm sure that's nice.
I have no aspirations.
I again,
I just want to live comfortably,
but once you fly in first class,
it's difficult to go sit by the bathroom
in between two other people like,
you know,
so there's certain luxuries that I want
to be able to afford.
But again,
I just want to chill out,
hang out in the backyard and have a
drink with my wife and fucking have
people over and barbecue.
That's it.
That's all after you totally do that.
That's,
that's very peaceful and that's a great
tHing.
And then also getting satisfaction out
of creating stuff and making stuff and
working at the same time.
And even if it's shit that I'm this guy
that I bought this house from the left
knee as table saw and all a bunch of
wood
furniture.
What are you doing?
Are you making furniture?
I'm not doing anything with it.
Are you thinking about doing something
like thinking about like,
I got,
use this stuff.
We know how to use a table.
Saw.
No,
we'll learn.
Don't cut your fucking face.
Never know.
Sure.
Now I'm gonna make.
Um,
he left like a,
some birdhouse stuff there.
I've just wanted to be the old man that
like tinkers and makes shelves and stuff
like that for people.
And uh,
my,
my dad was an artist and my uncle john
is an artist and um,
you know,
put together the sculptures with all
wood and he was like a very skilled
carpenter.
So I always like looked at those guys
thinking I gotta do this shit.
Then I just want to like,
yeah,
there's a bunch of shit I like to do
like that.
Like I want to tinker,
I want to fly fish.
Fly fishing is fun.
See,
I used to fly fish a lot.
There's a casting thing in the arroyo in
pasadena where there's a big arroyo
casting club.
Was all these old men just practicing.
Where do they fly fishing.
Pasadena's needs.
Is there a river there now?
There's a whole place where it's like
they've,
it's just a body of water where they
made me like a little pond.
Yeah.
so then they go out,
they take trips to places that I'll go
out and go to,
go to sierra and I was in bozeman this
center this summer,
bozeman,
Montana.
And we,
uh,
we went by this,
a place where all these people were fly
fishing and then maybe so excited.
I'm like,
god,
I want to go back and do that.
But it was weird because they catch and
release and I was like,
okay,
now you're weirding me out because
you're just putting a hole in that
fish's face.
Then you'll let them back.
Like this is kind of fucked up.
My buddy,
a daily show guy just went to Russia to
go fly fishing.
He's super into it and they bought a
place in upstate New York that has a
river right by it.
And just time,
that's because up for,
well,
if you can do like a place where you can
catch the fish and eat it.
God damn on the shore if you have a
little cast iron frying pan,
make little campfire and have some shore
lunch.
Oh so delicious for me.
That is the sort of ultimate hanGing out
with my wife having a glass of wine,
doing that.
reading and then going to bed.
But yOu really want to do it or do you
like the romantic idea of doing it?
We're going to fucking find out.
But right now it's just the romantic
ideal.
Totally.
Yeah.
But I do like going,
we've gone away in a couple of times,
like um,
my kids are just at the point where they
went away for a sleepover and this only
happened one time and me and my wife
drove up into altadena and heard about
this hike that people do and took the
dogs,
went on this hike and we had a blast.
And I know that if I could mix it in a
proper amount of work and the proper
amount of just chilling out,
I'll love it.
I have three hammocks in my backyarD
that I don't use.
I barely lanD them.
Yeah.
See,
this is what I'm getting out of you.
I'm getting that you're,
you're thinking about like this romantic
idea of relaxation and peace and quiet,
but look at our constantly vacation
homes non,
but meanwhile you're also planning on
doing a bunch of shows and being an
executive producer and a show runner and
a writer and a standup performer and
you're actinG and.
Yeah,
I've got a ton of shit going on and
you're yelling at people yelling
necessarily talking about eventually
getting
to a cognitive therapist and potentially
starting meditation.
It's like you have this.
I just do it noW.
Yeah,
well,
yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
You should have already done it like
you,
all these things you should should've
already done.
So this is the problem with me.
He's money.
Okay.
So the atc I don't do for anyone.
I have nothing but money in.
So that's not about money at all.
So that's starting like I started my
standup career eventually.
That'll be great.
No.
Well,
it takes a lot of work,
but that's just what is the idea behind
it?
Okay.
So we things comedy by the way.
So this is all things comedy is me and
bill came up with the idea that
comedians should own and distribute all
of their own content.
When I first showed up in la,
worked on tv.
So cheech from cheech and chong who told
me to do two things,
it would be nice to every single person
you meet out in the public,
uh,
every busboy is going to have the
teacher's an asshole story if you're
addicted.
Anybody.
So try to be as nice to as many people
as you can.
And then he goes,
also,
you want to own every single piece of
content you ever put out there because.
And he goes,
I owned all the movies and I owned all
the albums.
So every single day is all this mailbox
money and now we get put as comedians,
restarting I everybody starting all
these podcasts and this is 2010.
So we do all the paperwork,
we finally get the company and we take a
big chunk of the company.
And we say,
okay,
everyone that participates in this
network,
this is the board of directors,
thompson,
agora,
bert,
kreischer,
ari shaffir,
dave anthony,
myself,
bill burr,
and we help guide this place in the
right direction.
So when new comic wants to come on,
all of us sort of go,
do we want this person on?
For example,
john repin and tiana are going to start
a podcast.
I approached John Reed called me and I
talked to sarah and put them together.
Felipe esparza,
uh,
saw that no latinos are doing podcasts.
I know philippe's fucking hilarious.
And instead of like being all like to
the other latino comedians,
all competitive,
it's like fleabag,
you got to do fucking podcast.
And he started one called what's up?
Fool does great,
and it's helped out as numbers and
everything like that.
So we all collectively owned this
company together that distributes our
content.
So in this content starts with podcasts
would then eventually we started our own
studio.
We are redoing our website right now.
We're going to start selling our own tv
shows.
Burt did a cooking show called
something's burning.
Why?
It's fucking a tom.
And bill watching to most unsanitary
ever seen him play with his nose
touching is no,
quit fucking touch your nose one more
time.
I'm not going to eat any of that shit.
No one's going to eat that shit.
And they're fucking yelling at each
other while they're cooking and bert and
just dumped a bunch of oil down the sing
can.
Yeah.
You were making that and we shot for an
hour and tom and bill were hunched over
laughing.
I was in the back just cracking up
because he couldn't believe what I was
watching.
But what are you doing with it?
That should be a show.
Is it on anything right now?
So it's going to be on abc.com or we're
going to sell it as an individual.
You did it a long time ago?
No,
we just shot.
It was distance three.
Couple of months ago.
Weeks ago?
yeah.
Two weeks ago.
Three weeks.
Not two weeks.
Three,
four weeks ago.
And just haven't edited it or editing it
right now.
They're just putting it together.
So do you have like a,
a group of editors and stuff?
So we partner with this company called
soapbox films that has 15 editors,
animators,
all these people on staff.
So when you come by you'll see that we
have two full stages.
We have a green screen,
white cyc,
if color corrections,
you know,
a sound mixing studios.
And then they gave us our podcast studio
to different offices and then other
meeting rooms as part of like an
investment in us.
Wow.
So anyway,
but everybody owns everything.
We have atc records that again,
I haven't had the time.
We're just staffing up right now because
we took on a little bit of money.
But you took on money.
You know,
we've got an investor's.
Yeah,
we got investors.
Did somebody get out and given us a
million bucks?
Jesus.
yeah.
So the idea behind it is you're kind of
acting as a network.
We're going to turn into our own
network.
It's going to be like united artists and
when shows sell,
it's going to be full transparency.
When let's say something's burning goes
up and people start buying it.
Burt just gonna look at his back end and
know exactly.
You know,
the money has to be recouped and then
you know,
the money is split.
Interesting.
He'll just get access.
Like burt will own that if there's,
if there's a tv show that gets made out
of that and it becomes popular and then
there's the idea behind it that there's
strength in numbers and yeah,
we all,
we all really help each other out too.
Like if I'm,
for example,
I got this special coming out and
everyone's going to help me get behind
it.
When burt special comes out,
everybody says,
you know,
goes crazy.
We sort of do that.
Anyway.
We all do that.
Anyway,
that's the collection.
This is like,
um,
this is an association of comics working
together to promote each other.
And so like if you guys have a podcast
on the all things comedy label,
everyone knows,
well this is going to be pretty high
quality because comedians are going to
be a better show.
We're going to reign that in a little
bit like you said,
but for the most part we have a lot of
people contacting us and it's all
community of our peers.
We all really like and really enjoying
that or is that bringing you extra
stress?
It brings you a little extra stress
because they've put some money in.
It's definitely something I'm looking
at.
I'm getting to a point and empowering
other people that have some other comics
coming into help me work on creative
stuff.
But is it making money
or is it.
Oh yeah.
So we just um,
you know,
we haven't put out any of our tv shows
yet.
I mean I hope to have tv shows on the
air.
Let's just like funny or die makes money
off of unbranded.
I got to have companies come to us and
want scripts written and I was able to
give gigs to guys I knew on a daily show
where they get paid like $45,000 to
write a script for a corporation.
Oh wow.
And all those times you get gigs,
like we can serve as the agency for
that.
We can do,
I can match tom papa up with a company
so he can write their ad copy just to
bring him extra side money.
Like we can do branded content
integrated marketing.
And all that shit.
And have the comedians on the company
that does that.
Comedians are responsible for so much
fucking content.
It's books,
it's tv shows,
it's movies.
It's just like you're thinking about all
these comics are producing so much great
shit.
Then why shouldn't all the comics have a
company that distributes on it?
Well,
it's interesting because there's a bunch
of groups that are coming along right
now that are trying to capitalize on
podcasting.
And one of the things that's
fascinating.
I had a conversation with a friend of
ours who's got a podcast and his agency
or his management company that suck now
are telling him they want a piece of the
podcast,
fuck you.
And for the longest time they were
telling him he was wasting his time
doing a podcast and they were saying you
need to worry about like put,
getting a scripted show getting of this
and a dad.
And he was like,
I really think that there's something in
podcasts.
So they.
They were negative and they were
criticizing his efforts and now they
want a piece of it and he's baffled and
he doesn't know what to do.
I'm like,
you got to leAve them.
no,
you gotta leave them.
Absolutely not.
They're not doing anything.
Before I even talk to me.
I could have just a thursday.
No
sense in you.
You're doing it.
It's like this is something just like
your standup career than you really
don't.
Now because of the technology,
you don't need an intro to the
establishment.
When you're a young standup comedian,
you need a management manager and an
agent to usher you into the established
group of decision makers.
Right?
when you're a podcaster and you're
podcast becomes popular,
it's you and a room and that microphone
and people did listen and there's
really.
Because you're putting out a good
product,
you don't need somebody to tell you like
it's okay to do it or you're going to be
on this network like that's.
It doesn't matter.
You can do it by yourself and that's
another thing that I encourage all
people to do and this is a why am able
to like,
even though I am stressed out,
I wake up in the middle of the night,
I usually,
there's a lot of contradictory shit
going on and I'm looking at vacation
homes.
I love it.
I fucking love doing what I'm doing.
I really do.
It was great.
I love doing standup below the acting
like I just,
I love it all.
And to follow your bliss,
you know,
and to really,
I was fIring people and like you said,
do you have to be up In the rain to
appreciate the sunshine sake?
That's where I was when I was working
for somebody else,
even though that somebody else was my
parents and so I got down into standup.
I'm like dry,
look at all this great shit.
I looked right.
Even writing jokes are free for tim
allen.
Like I didn't have to do that.
Like,
I love doing all this stuff and so I'm
really thrilled like the people that we
get to associate with and the people we
get to meet and what happens when you do
something you love,
It all just sort of comes together.
So I feel very fortunate that way that I
get to do all this shit and even though
I need to say no,
I need to pare it down.
I'm still having a hard time.
Well it's good that you're having a
blast,
but uh,
my advice to you is just do all those
things that you're talking about,
like especially do all those things as
far as like meditation,
do all those things,
like whatever the cognitive therapy
issue that you have to deal with.
Just go do that.
Yeah.
because you,
you talk about it too much.
I know.
Yeah.
Like you and I have had like 30
conversations about your temper,
you know,
over like 10 years.
Like that's crazy and nothing's changed.
It's less because she got more and more
aware of it.
Right.
I'm totally aware of.
Yeah.
I've been so cool.
There has not been an incident in a
while except another night with steve
up.
Well,
that was a long time ago.
That was the other night we were talking
about the person that cut into applause
break.
Oh yeah.
Last week.
But it was just fucking reba
and again also,
you know,
it for a long time.
I'm not a in sync.
It gets also you caring about comedy.
It's terrible.
Really caring too much about comedy.
It's me being again,
sacrificing a lot to do what I'm doing
and then seeing other people are just
trying to fucking take advantage,
you know?
Yeah.
Like I love the idea of all things
comedy,
um,
but I don't want to do anything like
that myself,
which seems to me like,
god,
you're invested in yourself in a whole
bunch of other people's problems.
You know,
what I've kind of done is form a network
without having an actual network or all
the people that I'm friends with,
whether it's tom or joey or duncan,
I helped them.
I promote them just by just doing it.
I don't want any connection on.
I don't want any financial connection to
it.
You know,
I don't even have a fucking contract.
My manager,
we've been together for so long like I
don't either.
Our contract came up and I go,
I don't need a contract.
You need a contract.
He's like,
no.
Well good.
shook hands.
Gave him a hug so don't have to fucking
nonsense legal shit.
I'm never leaving him.
Been with him since I was an open mic or
I'm not.
I'm not going anywhere else.
No,
and that's also when we shot that a
pretty,
I'd say read this bird thing again.
There's no contract.
Beautiful.
Shake hands again.
I would die
before I fucked anybody overlay.
I'm really would die.
And so there's no contracts with us.
It's like we're going to make to put
that out there,
whether it's for free or whatever,
you know,
just we're going to start making shit.
And the most important thing is you're
having a good time.
Have a great time.
That's awesome.
Stover.
Laughing.
Couldn't stop.
Like.
It's not like.
The best part about this whole thing is
that you get a chance to hang out with
comics,
get a chance to have a good time.
Just in the more you do that,
the better stuff you put out,
you know,
the more you're in that vibe in that
group,
but humans,
you know,
just having a good time,
but you're putting out those good vibes,
you're getting them back,
everybody's producing good stuff.
Again,
I can't stress enough to people
listening and just finding that thing
that you really liked to do and doing it
is so fucking important.
I don't know what it is,
but if you really like something itching
at you because that's the thing with my
parents,
family business and even knowing I
wanted,
I knew I wanted to be a standup comic
forever and it took me awhile to figure
it out and so that's why I come down
here and I'm racing around,
like really trying to cram it all in or
whatever's behind it.
But I just wish that's a regret.
I do have.
I just started earlier.
How old were you when you started
telling?
Tell you I was 21.
That's one of those things though.
I mean robert schimmel started when he
was 36.
Start whenever you start.
Yeah.
No,
it doesn't matter.
I think oftentimes whatever extra life
that you have before you start,
it's probably going to help you was when
I started,
I was a baby,
you know,
I didn't know shit about life.
Yeah.
When I did start I was doing sales and
shit.
Like that was cool and Met life,
met life.
you've hung out with life.
He'D been there.
You've got down to nitty gritty.
I went and essentially like a couple of
years out of high school I became a
comic,
you know,
and I was out there doing the life.
I've never done anything but they have a
bunch of shit along with it,
but if there was ever a question,
someone said,
oh,
you have to quit everything except one
thing.
What's it going to be?
I'm like,
that's easy.
Stand up.
Everything else can go fuck itself.
Yeah.
without a doubt.
For sure,
because that's the thing.
As a standup comic,
we just always have this,
the skills to go out and earn a living
for all jay leno's faults.
He danced with some pretty great stuff
about.
There's a book called comic insights by
franklin and gi where he used to teach
at ucla and if you go through as
interviews with richard,
jenny and chris rock and jay leno and
jalen was says takes you seven years,
it's like a law degree,
takes you seven years to get your law
degree and then it takes you another
seven years to be a good lawyer and then
it takes you seven years to sort of
figure out who you are as a comic and
then another,
another seven years to be a great comic.
So around your 14,
15,
you really started hitting your stride
because you're great at it.
You're getting better at it.
And uh,
to do that at around seven years he
goes,
started making a living.
You can start really,
you can quit your day job and really
start making a fine living for your
family because you're making a least
like 70 to 100 is a long time ago at 70
grand a year.
Oh yeah.
Great.
Living just a,
you could live.
I'm going to a bunch of comics on the
road that just living in Indiana fucking
house costs $180,000.
A couple of kids.
Yeah,
totally can be done.
Total question and it's certainly better
than doing something that you don't want
to do.
Exactly.
For whatever.
You know the people that are listening
to this and they're like,
what is my thing?
It's gotta be something,
man.
You've got to be something.
It might be making canoes one of those.
What the fuck it is.
I was so miserable doing that family
business.
I started doing stained glass.
Stained glass is cool.
Yeah.
My dad did it and then I started doing.
I was looking for things.
I volunteered with the big brothers,
big sisters.
I was just held there like really?
And this is again where I single and had
the extra time to do anything.
Like this is what I'm out and I was just
looking for it and then I knew when if I
turned 30 and I didn't try stand up
because it always had been itching at me
and people always told me I should do
it.
Then I would never be able to live with
myself,
you know,
so I forced myself to do it and even
though it was sort of,
you know,
uncomfortable,
well this life is like this weird quick
blip and it seems long when you're
young,
but as you get older now I'm pushing 50,
I'll be 50 this year.
It just happens fast.
It happens very fast and if you're not
doing what you want to do,
it's not a fun time.
It's not a good feeling and you,
we all know that person.
We all know that one person that's not
doing what they want to do and it eats
away at them all the time instead of the
people that you know that are fulfilled,
that are doing things they enjoy and
they're working hard and they're
pushing,
but they get that good feeling out of
it.
They're actually pursuing what they
love.
They actually feel like they're making a
difference in their life.
They're actually creating something or,
or accomplishing something.
That's what you want to do,
man.
that's the key to getting those good
brain chemicals,
those good feelings,
having good people in your life.
Having good friends,
being kind to people,
enjoying your time in this life and then
doing that thing that is actually
interesting to your personality and your
mind.
So important.
And I'm taking a step away from work.
Again,
those deathbed lists.
You kind of look at these death bed.
I don't want to.
No,
nope.
Don't want to look at regret.
I get it.
I work hard.
I know what I'm doing.
I'm no perfect person by any stretch of
the imagination,
but I don't need to look at regret.
I'm,
I'm focused on tHat all the time.
I'm trying to focus on positive things.
I am absolutely aware of the
consequences.
You know,
I've,
I've contemplated it enough.
It's just not.
I think you could spend enough time
focusing on negative shit like what
people should have done and it can fuck
with your head.
You don't want to look up when I'm
Seventy and go where?
I
don't know.
You won't,
you won't.
I'm not gonna iF I died tomorrow,
wouldn't.
I'm good.
You just kinda keep going.
You just gotta keep enjoying it.
You know?
And who knows what this thing really
even is so weirdest thing about this
life.
It's like what?
What is it?
I mean we,
we,
we look at it in terms of this like a
sort of solidified structure of waking
up with the alarm clock,
getting your car driving to work.
Meanwhile the entire time this is going
on,
you're a finite life form on a planet in
an infinite universe.
I mean all of it is preposterous from
the beginning to the end.
All of it's ridiculous and the more you
look into it and the more you really
contemplate the absolute,
just massive scale of this universe that
we live in,
the more it seems ridiculous and the,
the little things that are keeping you
up at night and waking up at 2:00 in the
morning,
the ame zion insurance,
ridiculous.
It's ridiculous.
Shit.
Ridiculous shit.
Just a matter of perspective.
But I think it's also a matter of the
human body.
I think the human body is designed to
have a certain amount of stress.
You certain amount of worries.
The reason why we survived is because we
worried about predators are invaders and
all these different things.
Those things don't exist anymore,
so we give ourselves issues,
we give ourselves problems and I think
the way to mitigate that is to exercise
both in the sense of like a physical
sense,
but also like almost in like a demonic
extra cyst like get the exercise,
all that stress out of your body,
like you're there.
Your body does not want to be like this
overflowing battery of stress and
tension and energy and when it is,
it starts fucking with you to try to
give you pressure and stress and give
you like consequences for this,
for this anxiety.
I just have this insatiable drive that
leads to that.
A debilitating stress and anxiety that I
don't like.
So I think it's like what we're talking
about.
This is actually very helpful because
you don't.
I don't.
I'm talk to anybody about this shit.
I just talked to a doctor about it for
the first time talking to the whole
world.
Then
5 million people are going to listen to
jesus christ.
Alright,
I'm working on it right?
I know the absolute mess.
If you listened this far,
I'm definitely on an absolute mess.
I'm working.
You'd like.
All of us have issues.
You.
Everybody listening has issues.
There's no,
there's no perfect person and I,
I really did at this doctor's
appointment and I just flipped and I waS
telling.
My wife is aware of all of this and
close Friends are.
But I talked to his doctor for the first
time.
It was like talking to a complete
stranger about it and all you people
about it is very,
very new.
I don't and people are always wearing
that.
You know,
everybody laughs at me,
fucking stories of me telling People to
go fuck off
and they're funny.
They're not violent.
If
you meet me,
you by the way at the comedy store and
it's like I really am the fucking nicest
guy.
I am a very nice dude.
But wHen pushed and pushed and pushed,
I fucking lose my mind.
And when I see like the comedy injustice
going on,
I'm like,
fuck that asshole.
Fuck that dick.
Because it's important to you.
It is a consequence of all your
ambition.
I mean,
that's where all the stress is coming
from.
It's a consequence of view and it's also
one of the reasons why you've been so
successful that you're constantly
pushing and making things happen and
getting things done.
But occasionally you're going to spend
your wheels.
I'd like to come back.
Complete person.
No,
I'm not going to happen,
but the next time I come back on this
show.
Okay,
you're going to the timeline.
There's gonna be a little timeline.
Timeline.
I'm shit.
I'm going on vacation.
A long vacation.
I used to flip out on vacation.
How long are you on vacation for him to
go away for 10 days is a long time or a
date?
Three.
I start getting fidgety.
Do you start feeling like you have work
to do?
I should be doing work every single day.
If you go on vacation in los angeles,
you will get a call to be in a movie.
You can get a call to do all this other
shit.
And um,
that's always what I haven't seen their
seat.
I've gotten past that because I don't do
anything anymore.
I just do podcast and stand up and then
10 times a year and that's it.
I worked for the ufc.
That's all I brought.
I brought it down to 10 times a year.
Very great spot.
Your spot is the spot that a lot of us
comics want to get to.
I mean,
let's be honest,
you because you are able to do those
things because you have,
you know,
worked and you'd put it in all of you.
Put it in a lot of time to that and I
mean you working on talk radio and then
working on his radio news radio.
Sorry.
Newsradio working on a fear factor for
your,
you know,
ufc.
I like the gin being a great comment
because led to this,
you were able to be independent and
that's fantastic.
I hope to get you definitely tend to.
This fear factor thing taught me a lot
because it was an independent and I
didn't like doing it and it was a great
job and it was a lot of money and I
would definitely do it again,
but it taught me the consequences of
doing something that you don't really
enjoy.
It's not pAt,
I don't have a passion for.
I love the people I worked with and
again,
it was a great job.
I'm not complaining like,
oh,
woe is me.
I had a tv gig that went 148 episodes.
Crazy.
Yeah,
I mean this crazy successful show,
but it wasn't what I wanted it to do
now.
So while I was doing it,
it made me realize like,
okay,
this is not the good feeling.
The good feeling is when you're doing
things you want to do,
so figure out a way to when this is
over,
never do this again.
And so when fear factor was over,
of course I did it again when it came
again,
that they.
Because they came uP,
they came with the money so hard to
start thinking I'm a squirrel that money
away.
And then you know,
it's only three days a week.
What's the big deal?
You work four days,
you know you have four days off,
you worked three days,
you know that guy who's on big bang,
the show,
big bang theory.
The six lead.
The guy,
if you guys know the guy with the bowl
cut is even as like simon helberg think.
Um,
he,
I heard that he got his,
uh,
his deal for syndication.
They wrote him a check for $85.
Million dollars.
Yeah.
And uh,
started here,
but it's
not the two.
There's the two guys that are the main
guys,
right?
There's the indian guy and then he's
like the fifth or fourth.
Yeah.
And you hear about all these shows and
like backing up the money truck.
Just not a lot of those shows anymore
though.
They used to be like friends,
seinfeld shows.
Yeah.
All those shows,
those shows when news radio went to
syndication,
but new news radio was never the kind of
commercial success.
And then these other shows where it
actually became a success in
syndication.
When news radio was on television.
This was when,
there was not a lot of shows on tv by
the way.
There was one time where my friend lou
morton's,
one of the writers,
he would,
lou would wear a tee shirt that had the
number that we were ranked for the week.
Uh,
you know,
like our,
our,
our ratings and he came in with a number
88 on his shirt.
I went,
fuck dude,
where 88th,
he's like 88th,
like god down are we going to get
canceled?
And the only time we got cancels when I
didn't think we were going to get
canceled,
which is crazy.
But um,
I don't remember what my point was,
no issue working on all these shows and
that you're not doing ideally what you
want,
but then you know,
you have a,
a wife and kids and the money's so good.
I was thinking for the longest time they
didn't want it to be like an ethnic lab
brand on it and one of those in cis
shows where I are,
the worst guy just comes to come in and
the cops come in and I go,
you guys aren't gonna like this
sperm came back not to sperm the sperm
you think it is to.
I always think of guys like david
caruso.
I want to think of those shows where
they just kind of send it in.
Yeah,
they just mailing it in,
do that thing with his phone and get in.
Yeah,
every time you ever see that compilation
of him to just take him off of just
saying corny one liners and pulling off
the glasses.
Yeah,
that's what happens to you here when you
do one of those shows,
those shows are just designed to keep
grandma awake for another hour to sell
her tied and toyota trucks or whatever
the fuck they're selling the commercials
and then just brings me back to all
things count.
So atc is going to allow Just funny
people to make their own shit and make
it and sell it directly
to the people without having to do,
you know,
worry about this network rigmarole that
we've all been piped into the network
rigor bar,
all that was like a real.
There was,
there was that option at one point in
time that you thought that there was
going to be a pot of gold at the end of
the rainbow,
like a syndication deal and now that
stuff is almost nonexistent.
They cut all those deals out.
Yeah,
for good reason.
Awesome.
Ray romano story.
Yeah.
About him getting his check and he
sitting in one of these daily grill type
places like beverly hills lunch spots
where all the agents go and they go,
is agency does is check that you need to
probably want to just go walk away,
take a look at privately,
just walk away and he goes into the
bathroom and he goes in and opens up the
check and he looks at it and he puts it
back in and it's for,
you know,
over $10 million type of thing.
And he washes his face and he can't
believe it,
you know,
because this is a guy that was working
at a bank and then he was walking back
to the table and two for old ladies are
sitting there and they go,
excuse me,
and he thinks so everybody loves
raymond.
He's fenced and these ladies say,
could you get us some more bread please?
When you have a chance.
And it sort of tracking made him feel
like,
oh,
okay,
how could jesus like,
this is crazy that this is happening.
These Ladies have no idea who the fuck I
am.
They think I'm a waiter.
They're asking me for more water or
bread and it really took the air out of
everything and made them laugh because
you just got the fucking sweats.
Like this is a crazy thing.
There is this pot of gold for some and
when I started doing standup and I still
have all these deals,
that's what's happening with cvs and
there it's like I'm getting.
I've had my own family sitcom script
seven times and so like are the
development deals that give you a bad
deal.
Slava cash slab,
a cash and a script and matched up with
the show runner.
Show runners.
Last one is called call me al.
Then I wrote another one called mr
macho.
Mr. Macho is a good idea.
Is a good script.
Why the name though?
Oh,
so flip out a mexicans making fun of me.
Was it mr macho?
what's up bro?
Me,
me living in latino neighborhoods.
So then good stuff that could be a show
and you want to do that?
Oh man.
Right now I have my own like single
camera comedy on the air and yeah,
you like that as much as standup.
I love acting.
I love writing,
making shit.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Then.
Yeah,
and I really enjoy it.
Like it's got to be in the writer's room
on.
I'm dying up here.
There's one of the best experiences are.
And when does that come out?
When it's on showtime.
Beautiful hair.
You're gonna.
Love it so much I'm sure.
And it's kind of sexy bitch.
Look at you and that god damn amazing
outfit and that beautiful mustache.
Whoa.
I love it.
When you start dressing like that again.
Totally feel they look better with
beautiful apelles.
Alright brother.
So,
um,
this friday,
which is tomorrow,
I'm shrimping,
ain't easy on showtime.
Is it going to be available online at
all?
Well,
this is the thing,
they gave me a code.
So if you go to showtime or show.com
forward slash shrimping and I put this
up.
So this is on my twitter,
you get a free 30 days to showtime.
Oh,
okay.
Beautiful.
Launch.
A special.
You can watch it on the amp and then
that's the same is true for.
I'm dying up here.
I think I'm going to have another code
for that.
so you could really get two months.
Is showtime free out of this thing if
you just.
I,
paul put the codes up and people can
just grab the code.
Do you know what I'll do is I'll throw
the codes in my instagram and my twitter
of like the head bio or some.
Okay.
Let me just grab them from there.
Beautiful.
Watch it.
That's it.
Alright.
Now magically,
ladies and gentlemen,
shrimping ain't easy tomorrow.
Enjoy it.
god dammit.
Look at that back in new man.
He'll be back a new man hopefully.
Yeah.
Or not.
Probably not warm.
Which just more fun.
Alright,
we'll see you.
Bye.